Monka W.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Windows-Logik, Alter.
Can't wait.
Stimmt die Lautstärke jetzt überhaupt?
Moment.
Wo geht das jetzt?
Das ist jetzt...
Alter, das ist in Windows immer so nice versteckt.
Da findest du nix.
Moment, wo sind jetzt die Mikrofonsettings?
Hier.
Aber 80% ist okay.
True Morpher ist da.
Subscribt lieber nicht.
Wer weiß, wie oft ich da bin.
Moin Leute, schön, dass ihr am Start seid.
waren sogar schon Leute, bevor
der Stream online war hier am Start.
Was mich wundert,
weil ich war jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
zwei Monate oder so. Afk.
Was war los?
Nix, was ich groß erzählen will.
gestern, ja, wenn nicht
jetzt, dieses Jahr
noch, wann dann, ja,
by the way, ich muss noch Steuererklärung
fertig machen, null,
das ist jetzt wirklich so das Letzte,
letzten zwei,
drei Tage, ey,
dass es dieses Jahr fertig wird,
ähm,
so, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
aber schon lange nicht mehr gemacht ich mache mal kurz meine vm an und mach mal kurz package
updates weil das habe ich jetzt seit zwei oder auf ich habe keine habe ich war über zwei monate
oder so er kann ich war lange nicht mehr am start sekunde was ist denn die richtige vm
überhaupt das da streamende stream ist die richtige vm jama package updates das muss sein
ich habe bestimmt sehr viel verpasst ich habe nichts großartig verfolgt auf youtube
oder auf twitch oder auf sonstwas ich hab nur ein bisschen ab und zu
so nischen kram geguckt auf euren twitch streams also nix von den großen sachen mitgekriegt
wahrscheinlich ist es aber auch gar nicht relevant weil die sache ist ja so schnell
heb ich das drama von gestern interessiert kein mehr oder vom computer gesessen habe ich viel
es fliegt danke für den sub wie gesagt macht man langsam mit selbst wer weiß wie oft ich
am start bin kennt mich ja jetzt soll ich mal kurz package updates ich hab also ich
habe die letzten 14 tage tatsächlich sehr sehr lange und viel vom rechner gesessen fast mehr
als sonst was will das kuh im system chris okay das riemen wir einfach mal kuh im system system
chris was auch immer das ist was ist kuh im system chris irgendeine plattform die keine
ist wahrscheinlich okay kuh im system christus was also emulator vor chris ja
das ist ja nur zwei sich bescheid ja
der main trainer hat sich auch an wie einer von den 300 griechen so dann
Dann removen wir das einfach mal.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Okay, ich darf QEMO System Chris nicht removen, aber upgraden darf ich es auch nicht.
Okay, dann ignorieren wir es einfach beim Upgraden.
Was ist, wenn ich No sage?
Okay, wir skippen das einfach beim Upgraden.
Und jetzt removen wir QEMO System Chris.
Jawohl.
Perfekt.
Hast du POE 2?
also ich weiß nicht ob man es hier sieht also ich habe so ein paar also ich habe
period 2 gespielt und ich habe world of warcraft classic mit dem 29 jahre
jubiläums server angefangen zu spielen und beide sachen sind relativ zeit
aufwendig ja da kann man ohne also ich glaube ich habe die letzten 14 tage länger vom rechner
gehockt will der eklage für den sap excellent subskripten sie was soll ich sagen ja leute halt
euch zurück mit den subs wer weiß wie oft ich in nächster zeit da bin ja die
letzten 14 tage habe ich so viel vom computer gesessen also ich kenne das
schon gar nicht mehr ich war ich war das muss ich mir vorstellen ich war bin ja
das letzte jahr über ich war ein super sportler mit fahrradfahren und rennen
gehen also ich war seit halt euch fest seit dem 30 november nicht mehr joggen
und nicht mehr fahrradfahren will auf meine home trainer noch in echt gar
nichts mehr dafür okay ich gehe am tag noch bei ungefähr eine stunde spazieren
das war es dann aber und dann setze ich mich von rechner und cry in der pvp oder
classic 14 stunden am tag oder so muss auch weil ich mein aber schon die zeit
für hat das habe ich gemacht ja aber das ist ja schon das ist ja schon
drei, vier Monate her.
Ich kann das gar nicht mehr richtig, Leute.
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, ich bin jetzt ja
über 40 Jahre alt schon.
Und ich hab die letzten 10 Jahre
bestimmt nicht mehr so lange vorm Rechner gesessen,
wie jetzt die letzten 14 Tage.
So. Und ich hab
gemerkt,
dass man mit 40
Probleme kriegt an Stellen,
wenn man 14 Tage,
wenn man 14 Stunden,
Weiß nicht, ob ich 14 Stunden vorm Rechner sitze.
Lass mal überlegen.
Ich gehe morgens mal kurz eine Stunde spazieren.
So.
Naja, nicht ganz 14 Stunden.
12 Stunden?
Egal, lange auf jeden Fall, ja?
Und da merkt man das echt an Stellen, wo man früher gar nichts gemerkt hat.
Es tut einem einfach nur vom Sitzen der Arsch weh.
So, das hatte ich noch nie.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es geht.
Oder das Bein, weil man das eine Stunde schräg hatte oder so.
Ganz, ganz weird, Champ.
Aber es hat keine 20 mehr.
So, Update hat gefunzt.
Aber ich muss sagen, übrigens, und das bei dem teuren Stuhl, ja.
Übrigens, mich hat doch letztens jemand im Stream gefragt, was, also die Frage kam schon öfters,
Aber da muss ich immer sagen, muss ich mir mal Gedanken drüber machen oder fällt mir so spontan jetzt nichts gut genug ein.
Hat noch jemand gefragt, so Max, was würdest du denn heute nochmal anders machen?
Oder was wünschst du dir, was du anders hättest machen können so die letzten, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre?
Jetzt weiß ich was, Leute.
Ich hätte ohne Scheiß 2005, ich hätte einfach WoW spielen sollen.
Ich glaube, das ist was, das kann man nicht mehr nachholen, wenn man bei Release nicht dabei war.
Beides.
Aber ich will gar nicht so viel zu erzählen heute.
Ich glaube, das kann man nicht mehr nachholen, wenn man bei Release nicht dabei war.
Weil...
ist es so cool ich habe ja sagen wir so ich habe ich habe wollen vor kraft nie gespielt großartig ich habe damals
daug kreisel kreiselt gemacht und und gesagt
daug ist für noobs
war es für noobs daug ist für die elite gamer
aber ohne scheiß der der 20 jahre jubiläums macht echt bock
was aber witzig ist muss man echt sagen die mmo leute heute teilweise
Ich muss hier noch updaten.
Ich meine, das Game ist...
Mir läuft die Nase. Wartet mal kurz.
Okay.
Ich meine, das Game ist 20 Jahre alt.
Und
natürlich
ist
ein MMO...
Max, hast du den Song gesehen,
Nee, ich hab gar nichts gesehen die letzten zwei Monate oder so.
Weder auf Twitch noch auf YouTube noch sonst irgendwas.
Warte mal.
Ja, dass ich nicht vergesse, was ich sagen wollte.
So wie jedes MMO, was ein gewisses Alter hat, ist World of Warcraft Classic ja auch so ein bisschen Knowledge Check.
Problem ist halt, wenn man kein Knowledge hat
Weil man das Game nicht gespielt hat
Und
Es wird heute teilweise schon sehr
Optimized gespielt
Und ich bin halt der übelste Kack-Noob
Wobei mittlerweile geht's, denke ich
Ich meine, ich habe schon MMOs gespielt, deswegen
Es funktioniert allgemein, aber die Leute teilweise
Du verstehst
Du verstehst nichts
Wenn die sich unterhalten im Chat
Die unterhalten sich ja meistens
Nicht mal großartig im Chat
Du verstehst gar nichts
Okay, was ist jetzt aus diesen 15 Abkürzungen und Sachen?
Was wollt ihr mir genau sagen, Alter?
So, lasst mal kurz reingucken.
Haben wir irgendwelche WoW Classic Enjoyers hier?
MaxStream stellt.
Oh Mist.
Ich kann es nicht hören.
Ich bin ja auch hier nicht eingeloggt
Ich kann es nicht hören, weil
Aus irgendwelchen mir nicht
Weiter nachvollziehbaren Gründen
Hat jetzt über die zwei Monate oder so
Wo ich nicht, oder weiß ich nicht wie lange ich nicht gestreamt
Zwei Monate wo ich nicht gestreamt habe
Geht der Sound vom zweiten Rechner nicht
Ist das ein AI Song?
Ich kann es wirklich nicht hören.
Da muss ich nachher reingucken.
Keine Ahnung.
Der Sound vom zweiten Rechner geht nicht mehr.
Das ist auch so Windows-Kacke,
wo man sich fragt, wie kann das eigentlich sein?
Zuletzt gestreamt,
Sound ging.
Jetzt, zwei Monate später, streamgestartet,
Sound geht nicht mehr vom zweiten Rechner.
Einfach random.
Ich geh da einfach nicht auf.
So, Update ist durch.
Ja, Chat, was hab ich denn verpasst?
Ich hab mitgekriegt, dass sich irgendwie die Leute wieder die letzten zwei Monate irgendwie, keine Ahnung, über MrBeast aufgeregt haben, dass Honey irgendwie gescampt hat.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich weiß nicht mal, was Honey überhaupt ist.
Wenn ich raten müsste, würde ich sagen, irgendein Nahrungsergänzungsmittel oder so, weil diese Sachen scammen gerne Leute.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ansonsten.
Jet Planes Ride, da habe ich tatsächlich auf Twitter was zugeschrieben, das habe ich noch mitbekommen.
Eine PayPal-Erweiterung.
Reflink-Scam.
Achso, kein, okay.
Dubai Schokolade, Dubai Schokolade
habe ich mitgekriegt, Dubai Schokolade
habe ich sogar mal ein paar Stück von
gegessen und ich muss sagen, ich habe
null verstanden, was die Leute da dran finden
es ist einfach
nur eklig, weil es sich nicht richtig
durchbrechen lässt, du hast im Endeffekt
man kann natürlich sich so Schokolade
kaufen, einfach am Stück
abbeißen, aber wenn du es versuchst
durchzubrechen, quillt diese grüne
Paste die ganze Zeit
raus und das ist so
eklig. Ich hab mir
gleich gedacht, so ein Scheiß,
Alter, das ist wieder mal so eine typische
Hype-Geschichte, weil
es teuer ist, weil irgendjemand damit
angefangen hat.
Das ist nur Pistazien, ist egal, aber es quillt
trotzdem abartig raus.
Du hast halt oben und unten
Schokolade und in der Mitte hast du halt eine weiche
Creme. Das heißt, wenn du es versuchst durch...
Doch, das sieht
so eklig aus.
Wenn du es versuchst durchzubrechen,
dann läuft dadurch, dass du halt diese weiche
Creme in der Mitte hast, läuft halt
an der ganzen Seite permanent
diese Pistaziencreme raus.
Und wenn du ein paar Mal versuchst, das durchzubrechen,
hast du im Prinzip nur noch so ein ausgelaufenes
Stück Schokolade. Das ist richtig
abartig, ey. Sieht richtig eklig aus.
Und schmecken tut es auch noch nicht mal
sonderlich gut.
Also keine Ahnung,
ist das wieder für ein Scheiß.
Aber das ist ja schon wieder vorbei.
Weil solche
Dinge halten, ja.
Nicht lang.
Sowas wird mal
einen Monat gehypt, wenn es hochkommt.
Monat ist eigentlich viel zu lang, Alter.
Wie ist so die durchschnittliche
Hype, Schrägstrich,
Skandal,
wie auch immer Sache im TikTok-Zeitalter?
Was meint ihr?
Eine Woche eigentlich, wenn es hochkommt, oder?
Also eine Woche
ist schon lang.
Also wenn es mal hochkommt, ist es eine Woche.
Ich denke mal, wahrscheinlich sind die meisten Hype-Sachen, Drama-Sachen, Meme-Sachen, wenn es hochkommt, eine Woche.
Wenn es hochkommt, eine Woche.
Max, du hast doch eine Seite gesucht, die alle Techno-Seiten zusammenfasst, ja.
Oh, die sieht auch relativ übersichtlich aus.
Aber jetzt hätte ich gerne noch eine Übersicht.
Das waren die wichtigsten News diese Woche.
Also muss ich ja immer noch alles lesen.
Das ist mir immer noch zu viel.
Hast du gestern vom Lidl gecampt? Warum?
Also außer, dass gestern Feuerwerkstelz gestartet ist, wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Achso, ne, ne.
Moin Max, welche KI-Tools benutzt du?
Tatsächlich relativ wenig.
Also ich frage ab und zu mal Chat-GPT ein paar Dinger.
Das war's.
Was ich...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das erzählen soll.
Ich meine, natürlich muss ich mich auch ein bisschen, wenn man so in der Technikwelt arbeitet,
ein bisschen mit dem Thema AI beschäftigen.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
so die letzten Monate über schon,
habe ich mal die ein oder anderen
NSFW-Chatbots ausprobiert.
Und ich habe festgestellt,
es ist alles
absoluter
Schrott. Wisst ihr, was das größte
Problem ist, was ChatGPT hat
oder alle Chatbots oder die ganze AI-Geschichte?
Wisst ihr, was das größte Problem ist?
Die Dinger
haben null Gedächtnis.
Rein zu wissenschaftlichen Zwecken natürlich.
Klar, die Dinger haben null
Gedächtnis, null Erinnerung.
Es gibt
ein paar Tricks
oder ein paar, wie soll man
sagen, ein paar Versuche,
wie man das
einschränken kann, dass es nicht so schlimm ist.
Aber in der Regel haben diese
ganzen dinge keinerlei memory es gibt ein paar tricks ja also zum beispiel kann man das bad
als chat gpt hat jetzt ja mittlerweile so ein memory feature eingeführt man kann auch sagen
merkt ihr das und so was aber das ist alles sehr beschränkt und zwar mal nicht sonderlich
detailreich dann gibt es ein paar andere seiten die machen das ganze also ein paar andere bots
die machen das trick reich da kannst du beispielsweise wenn du mit dem bot irgendwie
20 Nachrichten gechattet hast,
kannst du sagen, erstelle
jetzt über eine andere AI-Seite
ein Chat-Summary. Also der
pipet dann quasi den gesamten Chat-Verlauf
zu einer anderen
AI-Seite, lässt das Summary
zusammenfassen und das
Summary wird dann quasi als Memory von dem
Bot benutzt. Da fehlt aber auch die Hälfte.
Also ganz ehrlich, das Schlechteste
an Chatbots ist,
die haben null Erinnerung.
Das könnt ihr auch ganz einfach testen.
redet einfach über Gott und die Welt, sagt, hallo hier, wie geht's und heute irgendwie wieder lange in der Bahn gehockt
und ja, gerade im Raum, keine Ahnung, denkt euch irgendwas aus, im Raum München ist das ganz schlimm mit der Bahn
und danach redet ihr, ups, jetzt bin ich gerade das Mikrofon geräumt, danach redet ihr mit dem Bot ein bisschen übers Mittagessen
und sonst was und dann fragt ihr den Bot, hey Bot, wo kommst du eigentlich her, blablabla, schreibt ihr mal so 20, 30 Nachrichten,
meistens reichen sogar 5, 6 Nachrichten aus.
Und dann sagt der, boah, und dann sagt der wieder,
ach übrigens, Bot, was meinst du, wie es heute in der Bahn war?
Und dann fängt der Bot auf einmal an, so nach dem Motto,
oh, der Bahnverkehr in, keine Ahnung, Bochum, ja, der ist ganz...
Also, die haben keinen Plan, was Gedächtnis in dem Sinn angeht.
Also, damit kannst du auch am schnellsten feststellen,
ob irgendwie was ein Chatbot ist oder nicht.
die Details von
vergangenen Messages.
Alle. Alle Bots haben das Problem.
Alle Bots haben das Problem.
ChatGPT hat jetzt ein neues Feature
für solche Memory-Sachen.
Aber das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber ich glaube, das musst du sogar manuell verwalten.
Die tricksen teilweise
im Hintergrund die Seiten, indem sie
deine Gespräche quasi als Summary zusammenfassen und in das Bot-Memory schreiben.
Aber dadurch, dass es nur Summaries sind, fehlt oftmals was.
Bei euch ist es ja so, wenn ihr mit Leuten geredet habt, habt ihr bestimmt so eine grobe
Sache von den letzten 15 Gesprächen oder so im Kopf.
Ja, ihr wisst noch, der Typ hat euch mal erzählt, sein Fahrradreifen ist kaputt gegangen irgendwie.
der regt sich auch immer auf über die Bahn und sowas in der Richtung.
Sowas haben Chatbots nicht.
Und das nimmt, wenn ihr mit einem Bot über längere Zeit ein Gespräch führt oder ein Chat gestartet habt,
das nimmt ganz merkwürdige Züge an.
Und da kommen dann auf einmal random Details, die es vorher gar nicht gab.
Also Gedächtnis ist tatsächlich, wenn man so ein Gedächtnis nimmt, ist das größte Problem von AI aktuell.
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile standardmäßig schon reingepatcht in Windows?
Das habe ich auch gar nicht mehr verfolgt.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich es ausschalten muss, sobald es am Start ist.
Ja, ist drin. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Was gibt es da eigentlich?
Recall.
Okay.
Okay, was?
Es ist so geil.
Es ist genauso gekommen, wie ich das gesagt habe.
Microsoft hat ja am Anfang zurückgerudert.
Ach nein, das ist nicht dabei.
Und das ist Standard.
Ist das in der EU auch?
Sixthand, ja.
Okay, wie schallt weiter ohne...
Der Alex Hack.
Okay, erzähl mal.
Okay, diesem Online-Get-Feature-Info.
Okay, machen wir das mal.
Alter!
Für Windows brauchst du ja wirklich jeden Scheiß.
Admin-Rechte.
Okay.
Also, was hab ich?
Feature Name Recall is unknown.
Okay, also hab ich den Scheiß noch nicht.
Okay, das ist nice.
Will das auch nicht haben.
Sehr schön.
Dann werde ich in nächster Zeit auch nicht upgraden.
Hat es jemand von euch schon untergeschoben bekommen beim Windows Update?
Microsoft Recall.
Oder seid ihr bisher auch verschont geblieben?
Updates habe ich alle gemacht.
Rebootet habe ich auch schon.
Bisschen lauter.
Ups.
Geil.
Wie ist das Website so fast?
aus des websites so fast wahrscheinlich weil die webseite aufgebaut ist wie eine
webseite von 1995 oder so html 4 nicht ford 4 hatte das old school
Haben wir hier?
Ja, wenn es knistert, muss man gucken.
Das ist auch garantiert ein Leckerli.
Kannst von ausgehen.
Die wissen auch schon genau, wie sich Knistern anhört.
Ob es einfach nur Tütenknistern ist
oder ob es Leckerli-Knistern ist.
Das wissen die genau.
Der Auer.
Scrollen wir mal hier
drüber.
Okay, kann.
Gut.
Ja, Chat.
Sonst irgendwas Wichtiges verpasst?
Bestimmt.
Was hältst du von Windows 11?
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen Abstand,
aber ich habe halt selbst Windows 11.
Naja, notwendiges Übel
könnte man es glaube ich nennen.
Notwendiges Übel.
Auf Windows 10 ist langfristig
keine Option.
Und
Windows 11, wenn man den ganzen
Scheiß so weit ausschaltet,
und das Startmenü entgruppiert und die Startleiste nicht so hässlich in der Mitte hängen lässt
und irgendwelche komischen AI- und Gängelungsgeschichten ausschaltet,
dann kann man die Sachen ganz gut ignorieren, wie bei jeder anderen Windows-Version auch.
Leider, und das ist halt so ein Ding, was sich durch die Bank weg hinzieht, die letzten Windows-Versionen,
leider ist das halt so eine komplett inkonsistente Masse geworden.
Mittlerweile Windows 11, ja.
So, ungefähr.
Du hast Sachen drin von Windows 3.11
und das ist immer mein Lieblingsbeispiel,
dass manche Leute nicht glauben.
Guck mal, nur nicht mal das fucking Anklicken von Ohr auf den Zuhänder.
Sag mal,
sag mal,
Ist nicht normalerweise es eigentlich so gewesen
Dass wenn man Sachen anklickt
Die weiter gehighlighted bleiben
Ja hier ist das so
Hier ist das so, guck mal
Hier ist das so
Hier ist das nicht so
Das meine ich unter anderem
Das ist einfach so inkonsistenter Shit
So, zumindest eine Sache, die ich dann immer gerne zeige
By the way, das ist ja auch übrigens der größte Witz, ne?
Show more options
So, eines meiner Lieblingsbeispiele ist immer noch das hier
Guckt euch, das habe ich schon 500 mal gezeigt
Guckt euch mal diese Hi-Res 2024 Icons an
Das wird aber noch viel besser
Ja, also zum Beispiel
So was hier, Ultra, Ultra High Res
Icons, ja
Also Leute, wenn das hier
Guckt euch mal das hier an, also wenn das
Hier jetzt nicht mal ein Icon ist
Was ich 2024
Hier, oder das da, ja
Wenn ich einen Ordner verwenden will, dann weiß ich auch nicht
also da kann mir keiner erzählen dass es nicht einfach wirklich ist
äußerst zeitgemäßes vector grafik passiert das icon ist das ist halt das größte problem was ich
auch mit windows allgemein habe dass das so ein zusammenhängen und zusammenhängen
inkonsistente masse ist das geht ja schon mit den sound settings weiter die
sie jetzt mittlerweile halbwegs hinbekommen haben in der richtung aber
ich immer noch nicht weiß wie ich manche sachen einstelle zum beispiel das geht
bestimmt irgendwo ich weiß aber nicht was ist zum beispiel wenn man jetzt
sagt dass es geht mir das alte sound menü geht und sagt hey ich möchte
beispielsweise das format umstellen von 48 kilohertz sind es ja dann auf 44,1 kilohertz
wer sich jetzt denkt wir brauchen so ein mist das brauchst du zum beispiel wenn ein audio interface
hast dass du per optischen tosslink kabel verbunden hast und je nachdem wie dein audio
interface eingestellt ist musst du halt auch deine soundkarte einstellen und mein audio interface ist
aus welchen gründen auch immer die fortmäßig auf 48 k man kann es umstellen auf 41 k also
letztendlich auch wurscht irgendwo muss man das in windows ja auch umstellen können so und keine
ahnung wo dieses gut beispielsweise dieses setting ist in dem in dem neuen menü wahrscheinlich hat
sich microsoft gedacht brauche ich übrigens es funktioniert einfach nicht richtig wenn das
nicht einmal könnte jetzt sagen oder lässt es halt bleiben ob jetzt 41 44
14 48 das ist quasi ein bisschen so wie das auch abgetastet wird das signal das
heißt dass im besten fall rauscht es nur wild im schlimmsten fall geht das gar
nicht also es muss schon im audio interface und in den betriebssystem
settings matchen
Ja.
Ja, Leute, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich da bin.
Sowohl heute als auch insgesamt.
Keine Ahnung.
Letztes Jahr im Monat war ich nicht da.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt öfters on komme in nächster Zeit.
Ich muss erst noch ein paar Sachen
Relive-mäßig klären,
dass ich wieder komplett der Alte bin.
Aber dann geht's weiter.
Auf Twitch und auf YouTube.
Wachst ans Trinken erinnern, das ist exzellent.
Erledigt.
Ich werde das mit Fedora probieren, bevor ich unter den FD...
Ja.
Musst du halt... Kannst du machen.
Wenn du...
Ich weiß ja nicht, was spielst du denn so?
Ich würde mal sagen, deine Chancen stehen ganz gut.
Dass es funktioniert.
Wenn du allerdings Online-Games spielst, gerade welche mit Anti-Cheat, kannst du vergessen.
Wenn du einfach nur irgendwelche Oldschool-Sachen oder...
Muss ja nicht mal richtig alles.
Wenn du einfach nur Singleplayer-Sachen spielst oder...
sagen wir mal,
bekanntere, größere
Titel, die vielleicht schon
1-2 Jahre auf dem Buckel haben,
sind die Chancen ziemlich gut.
Wenn was ganz neu rauskommt,
ist es immer so ein bisschen
ein
Gamble, ob es denn wirklich zufriedenstellend
genug funktioniert. Wobei man da sagen muss,
in der heutigen Zeit ist es ja unter Windows
gar nicht mal so viel anders.
Also Spiele, die gerade rauskommen,
du weißt ja nicht so genau, ja?
Wenn die released werden, funktionieren die jetzt oder funktionieren die nicht?
Ich bin eh der Meinung, Early Access hat sehr viel zerstört in der Richtung.
Heute kommt ja gefühlt fast alles,
ist Early Access.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Statistik gibt,
wie viele Spiele es überhaupt gibt,
die niemals aus dem Early Access rauskommen.
Was würdet ihr denken?
Also mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir so ungefähr 80% der Early Access Spiele kommen nicht aus dem Early Access raus.
Was mein ich? Also ich denke mal, das kommt ganz gut hin. 80%.
Und Early Access ist ja so ein...
Also für mich schon ein negativer Begriff, sobald ich in Steam was empfohlen kriege.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch da geht, aber ich kriege in Steam was empfohlen und denke mir so,
hey, liest sich ja eigentlich
gar nicht so schlecht.
Gucke ich mir ein paar Screenshots an und denke mir so, ja,
könnte man vielleicht mal ausprobieren.
Dann scrolle ich runter, sehe Early Access
und Instant Close.
Ich probiere keine...
Ja, gut, aber
Kickstarter, ich finde bei Kickstarter
ist das noch irgendwie so eine...
Da siehst du es halt, ja.
Da weißt du von
Anfang an, okay, das ist
eine Risiko-Investition,
nennen wir es mal, ja.
aber bei bei early access auf steam da da versprechen sie ja auch immer sonst war es
so nach dem motto regelmäßig updates hier und da und dann zwei monate später ist es
eingestellt zumal ich auch der meinung bin es tut oftmals dem spiel an sich und der
entwicklung vielleicht auch gar nicht so gut man denkt sich ja erst mal so early access
Das ist eine super Sache, die Leute können sich das im Vorfeld schon angucken und die Entwickler bekommen ein bisschen Geld und können die weitere Entwicklung finanzieren.
Soweit in der Theorie ist das ja auch gut, aber Spiele haben so einen kleinen initialen Hype immer, wenn die rauskommen.
Und mit Early Access tritt dieser Hype zu einer Phase auf, wo das Spiel eventuell noch gar nicht das ist, was es sein könnte,
beziehungsweise gar nicht in der Verfassung ist, wo es irgendwie Leute begeistern könnte.
Dann gucken sich das alle Streams so an, alle Leute gucken sich das an im Early Access und sagen, pff, suckt.
Und nie wieder interessieren sie sich irgendwie für dieses Game.
Selbst wenn es 2, 3, 4, 5 Jahre später fertig ist und deutlich besser ist, juckt keine Sau mehr.
Richtig, genau. Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich bei Early Access negativ sehe.
Echt?
Okay, da hast du Glück gehabt.
Du kannst mich genauso gut fragen, warum ich auf Twitch die letzten zwei Monate nicht on war.
Wie gesagt, ich muss jetzt noch ein paar Sachen real-life-technisch fixen.
Damit bin ich wieder am Start. Auch auf Twitch, aber auch auf YouTube.
Ja, Path of Exile ist Early Access. Path of Exile ist aber auch ein anderes Kaliber, was das angeht.
Die haben mit Path of Exile 1 schon gezeigt, dass sie das gut hinkriegen.
Path of Exile 1 hat ja auch quasi so eine
Art Early Access.
Es ist sehr umfangreich, es funktioniert
jetzt schon und vor allem arbeitet
da eben ein großes Team dahinter,
was bekannt für ist, halt auch
so zu arbeiten. Also bei Path of Exile würde ich mir
tatsächlich, was Early Access angeht,
noch weniger Gedanken machen.
Ich habe ja auch hier am Start.
Wobei Path of Exile 2,
da ist ja auch, es ist,
übrigens, ich hätte darauf wetten können,
Ich habe ja auch ein bisschen gespielt und ich hätte darauf wetten können, dass genau das passiert, was jetzt passiert ist, aber das ist bei jedem Game irgendwie so.
Das kommt raus, der Hype ist riesengroß.
Die Leute sind dann irgendwann, also gerade was Streamer angeht und Content Creators, sind natürlich super schnell durchgerusht.
Klar, ich meine, letztendlich verdienst du Geld mit dem Content und am besten ist natürlich, du kannst irgendwas zeigen, was sonst noch keiner gezeigt hat und endgame-täglich.
So, und da sind die jetzt quasi so super krass am Endgame farmen und das geflame auf Reddit, alter wieder, meine Güte, PersoVexile ist ein großer Schritt zurück und hier und das ist nicht richtig und da gibt es immer meine Lieblingsposts auf Reddit, ja, es ist, das ist, ohne Scheiß, hätte ich drauf wetten können, hätte ich irgendwie eine Wette abschließen können, dass das passiert, hätte ich genau das, hätte ich genau darauf getippt.
Meine Lieblingspost auf Reddit sind immer diese Dinger, sind immer die Abschiedsposts. Kennt ihr diese Abschiedsposts in Spiele-Subreddits? Es kommt ein Patch raus, keine Ahnung. Stellt euch vor, es gibt ein Game oder nehmen wir mal Path of Exile.
Nehmen wir mal Path of Exile 2. Es gab zwei Builds, die OP waren. Einmal Freeze Builds, war ganz grob umschrieben und einmal, wie kann man das nennen, Summon Builds.
und eigentlich also die frisbees ist das beste ist das beste beispiel gewesen du konntest du
hast quasi bosse zweimal gehittet und die konnten sich nicht mehr wehren und sowas ja du hast du
hast screen weit mit irgendwelchen brock effekten instance den screen gewalbt krasser noch wie ein
PoE 1 und PoE 1 war schon mit Endgame Gear sehr übertrieben schnell. Zoomkill, Zoomkill,
Zoomkill. Also noch schlimmer als PoE 1 war das. Das war so OP, du konntest quasi 30 Kilometer
gegen den Wind das riechen, dass das so nicht geplant war von den Designern. Und da gab es
patch und die haben das genervt bekannt sich jetzt zu überstreiten ob zu viel
oder zu wenig aber ich meine per se wechsel 2 ist eindeutig gerade in der
phase in seiner findungs phase noch so da haben sie das genervt abilities die
eindeutig so nicht geplant war und da gab es ohne scheiß es gab auf red hunderte
Abschied-Posts der Leute.
Add
Crying Gear Games.
Ihr habt komplett
meinen Spaß zerstört.
Ich werde dieses Spiel
nie wieder anfassen.
Die Zweite Güte.
Die sind ausgeflippt, die Leute.
Gut, sie hätten
eine Sache ein bisschen anders machen können.
Sie hätten den Leuten vielleicht
einen Respect geben können.
Respects sind relativ teuer, kosten relativ viel Gold.
Sie hätten den Leuten einen Respect geben können.
Okay, ja, das hätten wir machen können.
Aber diese Abschiedsposts...
Übrigens, die Leute, die sind wahrscheinlich immer noch am Start.
Also gerade die größten Poster darüber, wie schlimm das ist,
haben sich eh den nächsten Charakter gelevelt und sind schon wieder im Endgame am Start.
100 pro, kann ich wetten.
Aber das ist immer so.
Bei gefühlt jedem Game ist das so,
dass bei jedem Patch oder bei irgendwie,
dass die Leute immer auf Reddit solche Abschiedsposts schreiben.
Ich fasse dieses Game nie wieder an.
Der Hersteller hat komplett den Kontakt zur Realität verloren.
Wie kann man das so machen?
Und warum habt ihr es nicht so gemacht, wie ich das gesagt habe?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Da gibt es auch genug Beispielvideos für,
dass du in Path of Exile aktuell an sehr vielen Sachen stirbst,
die du einfach nicht siehst.
Am Anfang gab es Videos, wo du so Kristalle gesehen hast,
die dich in die Luft sprengen.
Da konnte man ja immer noch behaupten,
okay man hätte sehen können aber dass du quasi off screen von irgendwas gehütet
wirst und instand stirbt ja also ja also das ist wirklich abfackel period 2 das
problem habe ich nicht so weit bin ich nicht aber ich kenne es natürlich
verredet dann darf der menschen für den sap also auf reddit sind sie wieder alle
eskalieren
wisst ihr was für mich das angenehmste wisst ihr was für mich das angenehmste
action rpg ist das ist immer noch diablo 2 allerdings muss ich sagen nicht die
upload 2 wie heißt das wie master oder die
Resurrected, Resurrected, genau.
Nicht Diablo 2 Resurrected.
Ich spiele gerne Project Diablo 2.
Das ist ein alternatives Battle.net, kann man es glaube ich so nennen, für das originale Diablo 2.
Ich kann es mal zeigen.
Man kann es auch nur mit dem alten Client spielen. Das hier. Das spiele ich gerne. Das ist wirklich
für mich das angenehmste Action-RPG. Das ist nicht so krass wie Path of Exile überladen
mit 30 Milliarden Sachen. Es ist im Endeffekt Diablo 2 mit einem sinnvollen Endgame und ein
paar zusätzlichen Crafting-Möglichkeiten und ein paar zusätzlichen Drops und ein paar zusätzlichen
sagen. Also es bringt schon nochmal
eine gehörige Endgame-Komplexität
auf Diablo 2 obendrauf, aber
es ist kein Path of Exile.
Also das ist, wenn ich einfach nur ein bisschen
entspannt
Action-RPG'en will,
ist das so mein
Go-To.
Und es ist im Endeffekt nach wie vor
Diablo 2.
Du hast ein paar zusätzliche Sachen,
Ja, du kannst Items corrupten, also quasi entweder zerstören oder random Mods draufpacken.
Du kannst, du hast einen größeren Stash, du hast einen extra Stash für deine Charms und sowas.
Das ist echt gut gemacht.
Also wenn mal jemand wieder Bock auf Diablo, achso ja und das ist online wohlgemerkt, ja.
Also das ist nicht jetzt in reiner Singleplayer-Geschichte.
Es gibt ja für Diablo 2 Resurrected, gibt es auch ein paar Singleplayer-Mods.
Das ist ein Online-Mod, kann man es nicht nennen.
Das ist quasi alternative Battle.net-Implementierung.
gegen die dann der Diablo 2 Client läuft.
Und dementsprechend kannst du online,
du kannst traden.
Es gibt eine Trade-Seite,
ich kann mich jetzt nicht einloggen,
es gibt eine Trade-Seite,
ein bisschen wie die Path of Exile Trade-Seite.
Das heißt, ihr könnt wirklich
sehr viele Builds spielen,
die im Original Diablo 2
nicht wirklich viable waren.
Und an sich ist es wirklich cool.
Also ich kann das nur empfehlen.
Project Diablo 2.
Wer, wem
Path of Exile 1 oder auch 2
zu heftig an der
Komplexität ist und wer
eh generell Diablo als Setting
mag, wobei man sagen muss,
ich finde, gerade Path of
Exile 2 von der Atmosphäre
orientiert sich das sehr
stark an Diablo 2.
Aber falls jemand
das klassische Diablo 2 mag, plus noch ein bisschen
mehr Endgame Möglichkeiten haben will, halt
komplett mit Battle.net und Trading und allem dabei.
Probiert mal Project Diablo 2 aus.
Hat auch genug Spieler.
So.
Ja, da gibt es wieder
tausende Reddit-Heul-Posts.
Gut, ich glaube,
ich kann die vor allem ausmachen. Brauchen wir nicht.
Ich habe ein Problem.
Ich habe 500...
500 Milliliter.
Ich habe einen halben...
liter tee gesoffen freund und noch zwei gläser wasser ich fürchte ich muss
gleich ganz dringend auf klo aber schon mal und ich trinke jetzt weiter tegra
noch
Ja.
Ja, sonst kriegt man einen trockenen Hals.
Gut.
Soll ich mal wagen?
Gucken, ob es vom Fiat Champ was Neues gibt.
Ah, nur 40
Issues. Anwendungsfehler.
Anwendungsfehler. Da habe ich wirklich gerade keinen Nerv drauf, mich irgendwie um
meine Open Source Sachen zu kümmern. Krieg ja schon alles andere nicht.
Klingt komisch, aber ich feiere deine Kloschüssel. Ich auch. Ich auch. Ich finde,
das ist eines der besten Entscheidungen ever gewesen, mir einen Klo mit Spülung
zu kaufen. Also nicht
Spülungen zum Zeug wegspülen, sondern zum
Puppets abspülen.
Das ist beste Sache überhaupt.
Ich kann...
So blöd es klingt,
ich kann auf anderen Klos nicht mehr kacken
gehen, seit ich meinen
advanceden Klo hab.
Das ist wirklich
beste.
Ich kann nur noch auf... Das geht nicht.
Ich kann nicht mehr woanders
aufs Klo gehen.
Pinkeln kann ich woanders noch, aber
funktioniert einfach nicht.
Und wenn, fühlt es sich immer
falsch an.
Ich kann nur noch...
Ich wohne hier seit
2014, 2013, irgendwie so in einem Dreh.
Seit ich den Klo hab,
ich kann nur noch da drauf gehen.
Alles andere fühlt sich komisch an.
By the way, ich könnte
mal mein Swift-Abo kündigen.
Das mach ich mal kurz.
Zack, Leute, wo hab ich denn mein Handy?
Äh, wo hab ich denn mein Handy?
Das ist eine gute Frage, wo hab ich denn mein Handy?
Ah, ich glaub, das liegt noch auf dem Klo
Moment, ich bin gleich wieder da
Okay, so, das muss ich jetzt gerade noch mal kurz, sonst vergesse ich das nämlich nachher.
Ich muss mal kurz mein Swift-Abo kündigen.
Wo geht das hier noch mal? Hier, Subscriptions.
Swift.
Okay.
Ach nee, hab ich schon.
You've cancelled the subscription. Gut, dann ist auch gut.
Ja, weil wie gesagt
Ups
Ich war die letzten 30 Tage nicht mehr auf dem Fahrrad
Gut, dann lass uns mal kurz auf YouTube gucken
Was haben wir denn hier Schönes
How is this website so fast
Deutschlandticket
Betrugsfälle aufgedeckt
Oh nein, wer hätte es gedacht
Es gibt was
Und die Leute bescheißen damit
Damit hätte ja keiner gerechnet.
Also, in der Regel ist es doch so, mal ehrlich.
Die pure Existenz von irgendwas sorgt schon dafür, dass Leute versuchen, das für irgendeinen Beschiss zu benutzen, oder?
Sechs Dinge, die sich 2025 ändern.
Moment, das haben wir doch gerade schon geguckt.
Okay.
Lass mal schnell drüber scrollen, weil ich will wissen, was sich nächstes Jahr ändert.
Kurz drüber scrollen.
Ob da irgendwas Schlimmes ist.
Weil ich habe schon wieder gehört,
dass irgendwelche Politiker erzählt haben,
so nach dem Motto,
Deutschland-Ticket, das ist ja hier,
das wollen wir nicht mehr,
das muss nächstes Jahr,
wenn wir dann was zu sagen haben.
Wo ich mir jetzt denke, Leute,
das ist seriously,
das Deutschland-Ticket ist eines der wenigsten Sachen,
die ihr die letzten 15 Jahre auf die Reihe bekommen habt,
wo ich mal wirklich gespürt habe,
dass es mir was Positives bringt.
Natürlich wird gleich wieder diskutiert
darüber, das müssen wir abschaffen. Logisch.
Sobald es mal irgendwas
Gescheites gibt,
lass mal kurz drüber scrollen.
Das Deutschland-Ticket hat das Bahnfahren
deutlich unkomplizierter gemacht.
Es ist vor allem so,
jetzt mal ehrlich,
überlegt euch mal,
ihr seid Tourist und
kommt nach Deutschland
und ihr müsst euch erst mal mit
58 verschiedenen
regionalen Verkehrsverbünden
verbünden, beschäftigen.
Und ob ihr mit einem Ticket jetzt
Bahn fahren dürft, welche Bahn
oder auch Bus, es ist so
komplett für den Arsch gewesen
alles. Deutschland-Ticket ist tatsächlich
mal eine Sache, wo ich sage, ey,
das macht den Eindruck, als hat sich mal
jemand was bei gedacht.
Okay, lass mal kurz schnell drüber scrollen.
Als ZAIR in Zwickengroß
ermittelt wird, so wie es aussieht,
kaum.
Moment, was?
Wird es offenbar sehr leicht gemacht, denn im digitalen Raum sind...
Oh nein, das Internet! Leute, das Internet mal wieder!
Ich hoffe, es kommt nicht mein Lieblingsspruch, den Sie immer bringen.
Das Internet darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein. Please!
Sicherheitslücken groß und ermittelt wird, so wie es aussieht, kaum.
Kaum. Mein Kollege Jonas Helm, der ist in Köln.
Okay, ich predikte was. Ich predikte mal was. Wobei, ich bin mir noch nicht sicher. Warte mal, lass mal.
Im Thema, Jonas, du hast dazu recherchiert und ja, wir wollen wissen, wie funktioniert denn diese...
Okay, doch, doch, ich predikte einmal was. Es wird mindestens einmal das Wort Darknet erwähnt.
Betrugsmasche mit dem Deutschland-Ticket, kannst du das beschreiben?
Ja, die Masche beginnt in dem...
Okay, noch andere Prediction.
Noch andere Prediction.
Die Apps von der Bahn und den Verkehrsverbünden
haben irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken,
dass du darüber bescheißen kannst.
Oder dass du irgendwelche Screenshots von Fake-Tickets reinkriegen kannst.
Das haben wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwelche Leute programmiert,
die unter Zeitdruck starten.
Mal gucken.
Sich die Betrüger, die IBAN-Daten illegal im Netz besorgen mit diesen...
Jetzt seriously? Stinkt nochmal...
Ich meine, das hat doch mit dem Deutschland-Ticket nichts zu tun.
IBAN-Daten bzw. Kontodaten, Schrägstrich Kreditkarten, Informationen irgendwo sich besorgen und für irgendwelche Scamsachen benutzen,
Das ist jetzt auch nichts Deutschland-Ticket-spezifisches. Das ist so gefühlt älter als das Internet.
Die Mandaten kaufen sie dann ganz echte Deutschland-Tickets bei den Verkehrsunternehmen.
Das funktioniert, weil viele Verkehrsunternehmen bieten Seepalast-Schriftmandaten an.
Also da wird nicht überprüft, ob der Besteller auch der Kontoinhaber ist.
Und diese Tickets verkaufen sie dann weiter über Telegram-Seiten, über täuschend echt aussehende Seiten im Netz.
und da können dann Leute für oft weniger Geld echte Deutschlandtickets kaufen,
die aber eben mit geklauten IBAN-Daten gekauft wurden ursprünglich.
Also IBAN-Daten sind ja Kontodaten. Wie kommen die Betrüger daran?
Ja, also es gibt...
Durch Leute, die beispielsweise jeden Scheiß in ihren E-Mail-Anhängen anklicken müssen.
Im sogenannten Darknet gibt es...
Ich wusste es.
Ich hab's euch gesagt, Leute.
... diese IBAN-Daten für relativ wenig Geld
kaufen kann, die mal bei Hacks oder bei so
Phishing-Attacken abgeführt werden.
Okay, Leute, das müssen wir nicht gucken.
Das ist ein Losbeitrag.
Ich wusste es.
Da muss einfach
Darknet drin vorkommen in solchen Beiträgen.
Ich frag mich,
ich frag mich, wofür die Darknet
anfängt schon.
ja wahrscheinlich ist es eigentlich ist sie als falls das überhaupt noch jemand kennt
es ist schon da nicht so also das war jetzt nicht so spannend hauses website ist so fast
ok chat sagt das video taugt ich habe meinst das kann man auch gucken alles aus der fax ist
Darknet. Ja.
Erinnert sich noch jemand dran, als
die Corona-Zahlen am Anfang immer so
langsam waren und so langsam kamen,
weil die sich
auf der einen Seite eingetippt
werden mussten, per Fax
verschickt werden mussten an die andere
Seite und dort dann wieder eingetippt werden
müssen?
Das war, man darf nicht vergessen,
das ist ja erst drei Jahre her oder so.
Darkseid,
danke für den Sub.
Ich muss mich übrigens mal aufregen, wieder über Drucker.
Mal ganz, ganz, ganz kurz am Rande.
Ich hab's euch ja erzählt, wie begeistert ich bin,
seit ich mir einen Farblazer-Drucker gekauft habe,
ein Farblazer-Multifunktionsgerät gekauft habe.
MFC irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
Brother MFCC, die Dinger haben ja Namen,
das checkt ja keiner mehr irgendwie.
L, Ding wie irgendwie,
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, so ungefähr
sieht der aus. Ja, das könnte sogar der sein.
Gamepad.
Dankeschön für den Sub. Excellent.
Aber wie gesagt, haltet euch
zurück mit Gesabbe. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich
in nächster Zeit da bin. Nächstes Jahr
werde ich alle Probleme
real-life-technisch gefixt haben, irgendwann.
Und dann bin ich wieder am Start
regelmäßig auf Twitch und auf YouTube.
So, zumindest
seit ich dieses Ding hab, warum ist denn der so happy?
Ne, der ist gar nicht happy, der ist reingephotoshoppt.
So, also, ich habe euch ja schon ein paar Mal vorgeschwärmt, wie toll ich das finde, seitdem ich meinen Tintenstrahl-Multifunktionsapparat, den ich hatte, drücke, durch dieses Ding ausgetauscht habe, wie zufrieden ich damit bin und toll das ist.
Das Ding hängt im WLAN, das hat keine verklebten Tintenpatronen mehr und funktioniert einfach. Wie happy ich damit bin. Kannst direkt auf den USB-Stick drucken und alles gut, alles toll. So, aber seit zwei Monaten, drei Monaten, mediert das Ding, laufen die WLAN-Verbindungen.
und die WLAN-Verbindung,
wie es jetzt wahrscheinlich die Amis nennen würden,
die WLAN-Verbindung bricht einfach ab.
Und es ist nicht so,
dass es gar nicht funktioniert,
wenn ich mir gucke, ob sich das Ding per DHCP
eine IP holt,
nach dem Reboot. Instant, funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Aber es ist
nicht richtig erreichbar.
Oder zumindest nach
1-2 Tagen ist es wieder weg.
Und wenn man das Ding anpingt,
gehen die meisten Pings nicht mal durch
und manchmal kommen die zurück mit irgendwie
4-5 Sekunden Verzögerung.
Und es hat sich ja nichts geändert.
Der Drucker steht exakt an der gleichen Position.
Die Access Points hängen exakt an der gleichen Position.
Also da drumherum hat sich nichts geändert.
Da fragt man sich, wie kann das sein?
Meine erste Vermutung war,
die haben irgendwie ein Ablaufdatum in die Firmware einprogrammiert,
dass man gezwungen wird, regelmäßig zu updaten oder sowas.
Kein Schimmer.
und was ich gemacht habe ist,
also ich habe danach gesucht,
also müssen wir anders erzählen.
Ich habe mir erstmal gedacht,
okay, easy.
Stimmt es, dass Brother-Drucker
am wenigsten einem ans Bein pissen?
Ja, im Prinzip stimmt das.
Aber da komme ich gleich noch zu.
So, also habe ich mir gedacht, okay, was machst du denn jetzt? Also bin ich erstmal mit einem Handy dran, weil mit dem Handy kann man sich direkt mit dem Teil irgendwie verbinden und gut ist. Ging dann aber auch nicht richtig. Da habe ich das Ding ein paar Mal neu gestartet, bis ich per WLAN wieder ordentlich drauf gekommen bin.
Ich glaube, ich habe die DHCP-Lease gelöscht, sodass das Ding eine neue IP gekriegt hat. Zumindest ging es dann so weit, dass ich langsam auf das Webinterface gekommen bin. Wirklich langsam. So, dann habe ich über das Webinterface erstmal versucht, ein Firmware-Update zu machen. Das ging nicht, weil ich das Admin-Passwort für meinen eigenen Drucker nicht hatte.
Bis ich dann drauf gekommen bin, da hinten klebt auf der Rückseite, auf der unzugänglichsten Ecke, klebt ein Zettel mit einem kryptischen Passwort, das muss man da eingeben.
Okay, alles klar gemacht, Firmware-Update durchgeführt und ich denke mir so, jetzt wird es alles wunderbar funktionieren.
Scheiße war es, genau das gleiche, genau das gleiche Problem.
Nur, dass ich mir mit dem Firmware-Update jetzt eingefangen habe, dass der Drucker nur noch original Brother-Toner frisst und keine Third-Party-Toner mehr.
Die haben sich richtig rein gachi-bust bei mir.
Ich kann jetzt keine anderen Toner mehr verwenden.
Das Passwort ist nicht admin.
Das Passwort ist initpass oder steht hinten drauf.
Das heißt, die haben jetzt erstmal schön mit der Firma reingepatcht,
dass ich nur noch Original Brother Toner verwenden kann.
Nice.
Ist aber nicht so schlimm.
So ein Toner hält lang.
Dafür ist er teuer.
Problem war, geht immer noch nicht.
Verbindung kackt immer noch ab.
Ich ping das Ding an.
lass mal kurz checken, kurz, ob mein Drucker
noch funktioniert, ping, 1.2.1.1.
Ich glaube, 2.2.4.
Bam, er geht.
Nice. Also, Problem an sich
habe ich gefixt, ups, wir sind ja nicht unter Windows.
Problem an sich ist gefixt, also Drucker
funzt, so. Aber, wie gesagt, Drucker
ging immer noch nicht. IP-Leak, fuck,
Leute, seid ihr schon drin?
Jetzt vorbei.
Shit.
Ah, hätte ich das mal nicht gemacht, ey.
Der Chat ist schon direkt am Ausdrucken hier.
Drucker läuft schon.
Zumindest, es ging nicht.
Es ging nicht.
Das Ding ist einfach immer aus dem WLAN geflogen.
Also, was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe mal eine Runde danach gegoogelt.
Illusions-WiFi-Connection.
So, und dann habe ich einen...
Dann habe ich
einen Eintrag gefunden
aus dem
Brother Forum
oder so, keine Ahnung
wo das war
und jetzt haltet euch
fest, was den Fehler
What the fuck
Jetzt haltet euch mal fest, was der
was der Fehler war
Das hier war der Fehler.
Es ist zwar nicht...
Es ist zwar nicht dieser Post gewesen, den ich gefunden habe, aber das hat geholfen.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen muss man IPv6 einschalten, obwohl der Drucker in einem Nicht-IPv6-Netz hängt.
Und dann geht's. Über IPv4 wohlgemerkt geht's dann.
Hat da irgendwie einer eine logische Erklärung für...
Ich weiß nicht, läuft das mit JavaScript oder irgendwas?
Also ihr seht, mein Drucker, der ist hier über IPv4 erreichbar.
Und der hing immer sekundenlang, bis überhaupt ein Ping zurückkam.
Und die Lösung des Problems war, IPv6 einzuschalten.
In einem IPv4-only-WLAN.
Keine Ahnung, doch hier, das war die Anleitung.
So habe ich das auch gemacht. Und dann ging es. Dann habe ich den Drucker neu gestartet und es funzt instant. Guck, Drucker, bam, zack, antwortet einfach ohne Probleme direkt auf Pings und auf Druckanfragen und alles.
Da fragt man sich doch, wie kann das sein? Und vor allem, wisst ihr, was man sich noch viel mehr fragen muss? Warum tritt das Problem jetzt erst in den letzten zwei, drei Monaten auf und nicht schon seitdem ich den Drucker habe?
Weiß nicht, vielleicht hat da einer von euch
irgendeine sinnvolle Erklärung. Ich hab sie nicht.
Weiß nicht.
Vielleicht. Aber es macht,
sag doch mal ehrlich, Leute, es macht gar keinen Sinn.
Es macht überhaupt
keinen Sinn.
Aber man kann es nichts machen. Ich bin froh, dass der funktioniert.
Aber ich habe mich so
aufgeregt wieder darüber,
weil ich mir gedacht habe,
jetzt hast du dir schon einen neuen Drucker gekauft,
bist super zufrieden damit und er fängt wieder an.
Drucker sind wirklich so der Endgegner.
Irgendwas ist immer mit Druckern.
Es gibt eine Möglichkeit schon,
über Trick 17 die alte Firmware zu installieren.
Gibt es schon. Man kann
downcrayen. Ich glaube, über den USB-Port
kann man irgendwie downcrayen.
Habe ich schon was zu gefunden auf Reddit. Aber scheiß drauf, ich downgrade die Firmware erstmal nicht. Okay, how is this website so fast? Ich, okay Leute, ich stelle mal eine Vermutung an.
Die Website ist so fast, weil sie relativ minimalistisch ist und es nicht so sehr mit
JavaScript übertreibt, sondern einfach HTML verwendet, dort wo es HTML Features gibt.
Und ansonsten habe ich keine Ahnung.
Aber der Chat sagt, das Video ist gut.
Also gucken wir uns das mal an.
Ich meine, es sieht halt aus wie 1998. Das könnte natürlich auch dazu beitragen.
Es ist wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend leichtgewichtig.
Es ist relativ statisch, gehe ich mal von aus, bis auf die Sachen, wo es unbedingt notwendig ist.
was mit JavaScript zu machen.
Es ist wahrscheinlich so weit wie möglich
pre-generated, statisch
und minimalistisch.
Und dann ist eine Webseite auch schnell.
Nein, okay, siehste?
Stimmt nicht, was ich gesagt habe, Leute.
Sag da gleich Blödsinn.
Okay.
Und kein Endless-Scroll, ja das ist gut.
Endless-Scroll ist eh so der Teufel.
Okay, sie haben Websockets am Start.
Ja, böse.
Böse Zungen behaupten ja, ein Browser wäre eigentlich mal dazu erschaffen worden, HTML zu rendern.
Ich meine, ist in der heutigen Zeit nicht mehr so.
Aber doch, das war tatsächlich mal so.
Die primäre Aufgabe eines Browsers war es mal, HTML zu rendern.
Man kann es kaum glauben.
Aha, okay, das ist natürlich Sixthead-Time.
Wenn du über das Ding hoverst, könntest du ja draufklicken
und die können die nächste Seite schon mal quasi preloaden.
Das ist eigentlich sehr clever.
watch the URL bar and watch the actual page.
The page renders
before the URL changes.
And what's happening there is
they are simply just taking this HTML
Swap...
Macht SvelteKit standardmäßig, aber wahrscheinlich
nur wenn du SvelteKit auch serverseitig verwendest.
Also wenn du Fullstack, wenn du eine
Fullstack SvelteKit Anwendung hast.
Also dann wenn du SvelteKit
quasi mit Node laufen lässt
auf Serverseite. Nicht wenn du statisch
renderst. Oder?
Macht das das dann auch?
Wenn du statisch rennst?
Möglich ist das, diese Anfrage loszuschicken.
Das ist kleinseitig.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
das ist eigentlich so banal
und so oldschool,
dass es schon wieder cool ist, dass das immer noch verwendet wird.
Da muss ich jetzt tatsächlich mal was zu sagen,
was mich sehr gewundert hat.
Das hat jetzt alles mit dem Video
nichts zu tun. Und zwar
Microsoft hat letztens announced,
dass sich die URLs
für den
.NET Download ändern.
Weiß ich nicht, ob es da irgendwelche News gibt
oder so.
Ja.
Install Domains and URLs are changing.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich da gefragt habe?
Man sieht das hier.
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht checke?
Das ist doch Microsoft, wovon wir hier reden.
So.
Und die sagen, ihre .NET Sachen, wenn du sie downloadest,
sind auf einem Azure Content Delivery Network gehostet.
Da würde man auch eigentlich von ausgehen, das sind Domains von Microsoft bzw. auch ein Service von Microsoft.
Aber ist es nicht.
Weder die Domains noch der Service ist von Microsoft, sondern die sind von Edge.io und die sind pleite gegangen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, hä?
Hat Microsoft nicht selbst genug Domains und genug Kapazitäten und genug Cloud, um so essentielle Sachen wie ihre .NET Installer selbst zu hosten?
Da habe ich wirklich nur noch so dargestellt. Hä?
Ich verstehe das ganze Ding nicht. Wie kann das sein?
so habe ich da da gesagt
ich verstehe was da steht, aber
ich verstehe nicht warum
ich meine Microsoft ist doch
irgendwie kleiner
Indie Developer und
Cloud Anbieter
der
das habe ich null kapiert
ich habe es innerlich verstanden
aber warum das überhaupt
jemals so passiert
keine Ahnung, das hat sich mir nicht erschlossen
Da wollte jemand Geld sparen, ja anscheinend.
Ja, wegen dem Namen ist mir das eingefallen, ja.
Hier ist das Netzwerk.
Wenn ich es auslöse und auf die Homepage klicke,
dann seht ihr, dass es 65 Millisekunden dauert, um diese Seite zu laden.
Das ist sehr, sehr schnell, wenn man von der Server kommt.
Aber wenn ich diese Seite hier nachschließe,
dann seht ihr, dass es jetzt 7 Millisekunden dauert.
Das ist, weil sie es in CDNs auf der ganzen Welt kassieren,
aber sie kassieren es auch in eurem Browser,
mit einem Serviceworker.
Und was das uns ermöglicht, ist, dass man Requesten mit einem Serviceworker unterhalten kann und dann den Cash-Rush-Termin aufrufen kann.
zusätzliches javascript pfeil hinlegen was was quasi in einem service worker
läuft dass das das redet dann über events mit deinem browser macht aber
kaum jemand
max machst du dir gedanken beim arbeiten so
wenig energie zu verbrauchen wie nötig
Moment, meinst du jetzt Energie in Form von Stromverbrauch oder so daheim?
Oder meinst du, ich möchte während der Arbeitszeit mein Gehirn so wenig wie möglich belasten, dass ich danach noch genug Kapazitäten in meinem Hirn frei habe, um das zu machen, worauf ich Bock habe?
Was meinst du mit so wenig Energie verbrauchen wie möglich?
Du meinst Stromverbrauch vermutlich, oder?
Aber ehrlich gesagt mache ich mir um den Stromverbrauch keine Gedanken. Ich glaube, ich habe dieses Jahr so viel Stromverbrauch wie noch nie, weil es mir irgendwie kalt ist dieses Jahr und ich öfters mal meine Klimaanlage benutze, um zu heizen.
Also ich habe die Heizung an, aber gerade wenn ich hier ins Arbeitszimmer komme und drauf gucke und feststelle, Moment, lass mich mal gucken, es ist gerade nur 18,9 Grad, obwohl die Heizung auf 23 Grad steht.
aber das Thermostat an der Heizung hat einen schweren Job, die Heizung zu regulieren, weil das Thermostat ist unter einem Kabelkanal und da staut sich die warme Luft und es denkt, es ist viel wärmer hier drin, als es eigentlich ist.
Und dann, das ist tatsächlich eine Wärmepumpe, wenn man es genau nimmt, die Klimaanlage.
Und dann drücke ich jetzt einfach mal hier auf die Fernbedienung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gehört habt, jetzt geht meine Klimaanlage an, aber im Heizmode.
Und wird gleich anfangen, hier warme Luft in den Raum zu blasen.
Und wenn es dann 21 Grad ist, dann mache ich die einfach wieder aus.
Und das hält dann auch, solange ich die Tür zu habe.
Dann muss ich dann, keine Ahnung, ich muss dann alle Stunde mal kurz anmachen und das
ist gut.
Ja, nee, also ich guck da nicht wirklich drauf.
Was ich mache ist, ich schau das allgemein nicht so viel unnötiges Zeugs.
Ja, also zum Beispiel, dass ich jetzt irgendwie nicht den Fernseher im Stand-by lasse,
wenn das einer ist, der viel verbraucht, sondern dass man den quasi mit einer Wi-Fi-Steckdose ausschalten kann.
oder
ja, das nicht irgendwie
im Hof
des Ganztagtes,
die Beleuchtung, alles, sowas.
Aber ansonsten
mache ich nichts großartig.
Richtung Optimierung?
Nee, nee.
Also ich habe zwar vieles, was man hier daheim
heimautomatisiert und was man ja
steuern kann, aber
ich würde nicht sagen,
dass ich jetzt ein großer
Stromsparoptimierer
bin. Ja, ich weiß.
Aber ich weiß
nicht, deswegen sage ich, haltet
euch zurück mit Sam. Ich weiß nicht,
wie oft ich am Start
bin in nächster Zeit.
Aber wenn ich meine ganzen
Geschichten behoben
habe und gefixt habe,
Relive-technisch,
dann bin ich wieder voll am Start, auch auf Twitch
und auf YouTube.
Moin. So, jetzt gucken wir das Video einmal weiter.
Genau, bei PWA ist der Klamau haben wir gerade.
Moment, Moment.
Ist das etwa Razorpages?
Wenn die Server-Site Rendering verwenden mit ASP.NET.
Sag bloß, gibt es tatsächlich noch Leute, die das verwenden?
... into what's going on right here.
These right here, these link preloads...
mcmaster.com
... tell the browser,
hey, I'm going to need this right here, that's their logo,
and these are all web fonts.
And it's telling the browser, hey, I know you don't know this yet,
but I need you...
Übrigens, das ist auch was, wo man, also wenn man mal das braucht,
was Schriftarten angeht, kann man auch extrem viel optimieren,
was Webseiten angeht.
Man kann sich zum Beispiel Custom Fonts erstellen, die, also auch mit Icons und sowas, die wirklich nur exakt das enthält, was die Webseite braucht. Normalerweise ist das ziemlich egal, ja, ob jetzt beispielsweise dort ein paar Kilobyte mehr runtergeladen werden im Hintergrund oder nicht, ist für den Desktop-Browser und die Desktop-Internet ist es vollkommen egal, wo das tatsächlich relativ relevant ist, wenn ihr zum Beispiel mal was für einen Microcontroller programmiert.
Ja, Microcontroller haben ja heutzutage auch oftmals ein Webfrontend, ja, denkt euch hier WLAN-Klübirne oder so, ja, die haben dann oftmals auch ein Webfrontend, kommst du drauf, kannst Sachen einstellen und sonst was oder irgendwelche Sensoren, Temperatursensoren und sonst was.
Microcontroller mit Webfrontend
und das Webfrontend sollte ja auch nicht
wie Kürze aussehen
und dort, wenn du Icons
brauchst und Fonts
so eine Microcontroller hat halt oftmals
nur ein paar Kilobyte oder
ja gut, die neueren sind, also gerade
wenn man sich die neuen ESPs anguckt
die sind schon recht geräumig mit 4 Megabyte
plus für die Anwendung
aber da ist das teilweise sinnvoll
weil so eine Schriftart kann durchaus mal
2, 3, 400 Kilobyte groß sein
Und wenn man dort nur eine Custom-Schrift erstellt, gibt es ein paar Services für, wo man das auswählen kann.
Selected einfach die Icons, die man haben will.
Schriftdaten wird oftmals für Icons verwendet.
Da kann man das von 400 Kilobyte runter auf, keine Ahnung, 1 Kilobyte bringen.
Geil, weiter.
Ich möchte die Fonts vorab für mich downloaden, damit sie, wenn ich sie brauche, sofort aufladen können.
Moin, TakeVIAGRA3R, danke für den Sub.
Ja, ich habe mir gedacht, wenn nicht jetzt, wann dann?
Ja, und jetzt kann es schon, während es die Seite rendert, quasi im Hintergrund den Download anschmeißen.
Ich habe das gefunden, dass ich eine Web-Fonte brauche.
Also braucht es zwei oder drei Wasserfall-Rechte, bevor man sie tatsächlich dazu bekommt.
Und indem man sie in den Kopf pre-loadet, bevor es sogar weiß, dass es CSS braucht,
wird es bereits diese File hot and ready für dich haben, wie kleine Kaisers, richtig?
Dies auch DNS-Pre-Fetch.
Teil des Request-Zyklus ist natürlich, dass du die echte Bilder downloaden musst.
Seriously, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass es existiert.
Kennt das jemand von euch?
Dieses, was ist ein Attribut dann, ne?
Dieses Attribut bei Link,
das ist ja da DNS an,
aber ich hab das noch nie gesehen bis jetzt.
Wusste nicht, dass das existiert.
Ich hab das noch nie gesehen.
Ich weiß diese Teilheit, und es wird kein DNS-Bereich sein.
Ist die Webseite eher so 2005?
Also so krass schnell kommt es mir jetzt eigentlich...
Oder doch, wenn du die...
Naja.
Naja, also...
Ich weiß nicht.
Entweder ist mein Browser einfach kaputt
und funktioniert nicht, was er da zeigt.
Aber für mich fühlt sich die Webseite, ehrlich gesagt, ganz normal an.
Ohne jetzt was Spezielles und es lädt auch nach.
Critical CSS.
Oh ne, Leute.
CSS-Time.
Alles inline, hä?
Oh ja, kann man machen.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal die Webseite an.
Sonderlich viel Styling braucht ihr ja gar nicht.
Ups.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt
irgendein Vite-Plugin oder so.
Ich sage absichtlich nicht Webpack,
weil Webpack gibt es tausend Plugins,
aber niemand mag Webpack.
Was das auch macht, oder?
So nach dem Motto,
pack alles inline in die Seite.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es da einen Namen für gibt.
Ja, macht Sinn.
Übrigens, by the way,
guckt euch mal an,
mit wie wenig
CSS, die letztendlich auskommen
für das Basic Styling von der Seite.
Ja, die haben ihre
Futterbar.
Navigation.
Dann irgendwie
dieses Spaltenlayout.
Die Seite
sieht halt auch sehr basic, sagen wir mal, aus.
Aber für so einen Shop
ist das eher was Gutes als was Schlechtes.
Weil du willst einfach, dass so wenig
Leute wie möglich im Bestellprozess
oder im Empfindungsprozess
irgendwie hängenbleiben.
Und es hat einen weiteren Vorteil,
dass solche Webseiten eigentlich
standardmäßig auch auf dem Smartphone
ganz brauchbar aussehen, weil
der Smartphone-Browser die ganz gut skalieren
kann, wenn da nichts großartig Magic
passiert.
Da musst du dir dann gar keine großartigen
Gedanken um Responsive
Design und Media Queries
und sonst was machen, wenn die Seite einfach
so nur aus Text besteht.
Klappt das. Können wir mal ausprobieren,
wie das für uns MCMaster.com
tun wir mal so, als sind wir auf dem Smartphone
äh
Chatgeber, wo ist der Knopf dafür? Das hier?
Ja
äh, okay, ne, das funktioniert
nicht so, nicht so
richtig gut
wobei doch, funktioniert ganz gut
die, meine Anzeige sackt einfach nur
würde wahrscheinlich aufs Malen von auch
ganz gut funktionieren, ja
ich muss das gerade mal auf dem Handy aufmachen
dieser, dieser simulierte Browser-Modus
funzt oftmals, ne
Master
Da kommen...
Ja, die Seite sieht super auf Menus,
aber da haben sie sich ein bisschen...
Okay, es ist ein bisschen CSS drin,
was das Ganze dann letztendlich umbricht
für das Smartphone.
Ja, das ist schon drin.
Aber man kommt mit relativ wenig CSS aus.
Und wenn du ein paar CSS-Sendungen hast, dann ist es in einem Moment...
Es fängt an spürbar zu werden.
Unter 50 Millisekunden. Gut.
Und bei Webseiten reden wir einfach mal
vom Dreifachen und es ist immer noch schnell.
Man ladet mal fucking Facebook oder sowas.
Das hat irgendwie 21 MB JavaScript.
Zumindest war das mal so.
Mittlerweile vielleicht auch nicht mehr.
Und lädt Kanon
acht Sekunden oder so ohne Cache.
das hat das jetzt einfach mal ich bin nicht oft auf ich habe nicht mal in facebook account ich
will auch gar nicht hin aber das war immer so ein negativ beispiel für seiten die super fett sind und
ewig brauchen das ist extrem liefer das 174 millisekunden hat das preloaded css und
nothing das note jank das das das einzige was du siehst ist das es eine split second
während diese Bilder aufladen, aber nichts anderes bewegt sich auf der
Seite, wenn wir das tun, theoretisch könnten die wahrscheinlich sogar
die Bilder noch in der Seite verbinden, jetzt sprechen wir
über die echten Bilder, gerade die kleinen Bilder, die sind
ja auch nicht groß, die kannst du als Base64 encoded
wie nennt sich das, Data Source URL oder sowas, kannst du die wahrscheinlich sogar
im Bett darin auf der Seite, also eine Sache, die sie tun, wenn du
im speck element an die stings hier ist er herr fix witten heizt für der
aktuelle images und was erlässt du dir ist der browser das know how large in
images going to be it's going to give it 0 pixels bei 0 pixels
er gut anspringt die seite so rum denn es downloaden und dann er hat es
gepusht haben der kontakt stimmt das ist größer aber es braucht kein extra
request für die bilder
ich würde mal behaupten die bandbreite ist nicht wirklich das problem sondern
diese roundtrip zeit so für mehrere request es macht es wahrscheinlich in der
summe langsamer
Das ist clever.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, die laden die Images einzeln.
Das ist natürlich eine schlaue Geschichte.
Die laden das Bild nur einmal und schneiden sich dann quasi raus, was sie brauchen.
Das sind alle Bilder für diese Seite in einer einzigen Bild. Und was das macht, ist, dass es die Anzahl an Requesten, die eigentlich benötigt werden, aufschluckt.
Okay, das ist nicht schlecht.
Also es downloadet nur eine Bild. 93k. Also, ja, 93k wert von echten Bildern. Das ist ziemlich nüftig. Das ist wahrscheinlich kleiner als eine Bild auf Amazon.
Ja, genau.
und sie laden nur das JavaScript auf diese Seite.
Ich nenne das Dependency Injection in der Tweet.
Die Leute sind verrückt.
Sie sagen, ich brauche diese Dependencies für diese Seite,
also laden sie nur auf diese Seite.
Und wenn du ein Bild nimmst,
Es juckt jedem in den Fingern.
Sobald jemand was sieht,
wo er auch nur entfernt von Ahnung hat
und meint, das ist vielleicht nicht
hundertprozentig korrekt ausgedrückt,
dann müssen wir gleich posten.
Instant muss dann gepostet werden.
Alter, was bist du für ein Depp?
Warum schreibst du so eine Scheiße?
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
In meinen 580 Jahren Berufserfahrung
ist mir nie so etwas Blödes untergekommen.
Dann flippen die Leute immer voll aus.
Also Leute im Internet korrigieren,
da haben sie echt einen ganz großen Hang zu.
starten, hier herumklicken und eine der Produktpages schauen. In der Antwort wird oft
etwas Daten in diesem kleinen Metadata, das zeigt, was es mit JavaScript braucht.
Yo, Dog, I put your data in your data.
JS include file paths. So they must have some tooling on the back end that will split
up the JavaScript by page. That's very easy to do if you're using a server-rendered React
Framework, you don't have to worry about it,
but there are lots of websites
out there that simply just load all the
JavaScript on all the pages, because it's
too hard to figure out what JavaScript
is actually needed.
So it looks, I don't know much about
ASP.NET, this might be just part of their
Web Framework, but
Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Also, Moment, das ist ASP,
ist das noch
nicht mal ASP.NET Core, ist das noch
älter?
Sind das überhaupt schon Razor Pages?
sind das so Webforms?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
By the way, die Bahn-Webseite
basierte auch lange Zeit
auf OldschoolASP.net.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist.
Was ich lustig fand,
früher bei der Bahn-Webseite,
ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist,
wenn man jetzt hier mal zum Beispiel sucht
von, keine Ahnung, von Frankfurt
nach München
oder so.
nein das ist nicht mehr so damals neu gebaut
früher war die url hier oben irgendwas mit asp.net exe stand da drin
das ist das wort exe gelesen habe in der url habe ich auch noch okay was bei der
bahn los nee das anscheinend nicht mehr so
JQuery.
Das ist von seinem Plugin, ja.
Oder nicht.
auf dieser Seite, um sicherzustellen, dass es wirklich gut funktioniert.
Aber ich habe mich umgekehrt, um zu sehen, was sie verwenden.
Und sie verwenden YUI.
Das ist ja uralt.
2008, let's go.
So sieht es aus.
Das ist YUI, Copyright 2008.
Das ist eine sehr, sehr alte Bibliothek.
Ein kostenloses Open-Source-JavaScript- und CSS-Library
für die Bildung von reichlich interaktiven Web-Applikationen.
Übrigens, nochmals zu 15-year-old-tech.
Wisst ihr, was das nervigste und schlimmste JavaScript-Frontend-Ding ist, was ich gesehen habe bisher?
Obwohl wir gerade bei alten Sachen sind, ja.
Das ist ext.js.
Kennt das jemand noch?
Das ist ein Framework, das hat versucht, so ein bisschen wie eine Java-UI im Browser zu bauen.
Ja, so sieht das aus zum Beispiel.
Ja, genau, ja.
Das ist ganz grausam, Alter.
Immer wenn ich das sehe, kriege ich Ausschläge.
Kennt das jemand?
By the way, TV Headend basiert auch da drauf.
Das, das, äh, GUI.
Ganz, ganz grausam.
Das ist aber auch schon 20 Jahre alt oder so.
Es ist wirklich interessant für mich. Es gibt Teile auf der Website, wo sie langsam werden,
weil ich sicher bin, dass sie 700.000 Produkte hier haben. Sie müssen
Daten-Base-Schau-Ups langsam machen. Ich bin sicher, dass sie viel Zeit verbraucht haben, um den
Perf zu verbessern. Sie müssen alles auslösen. Sie müssen alles kassieren.
Also, es gibt, schau dir das an. Also in diesem Fall war es ein ziemlich guter Spinner,
auf dieser Seite zu zeigen. Nicht brutal, aber ich bin hier auf einem ziemlich schnellen Internet. Ich bin sicher,
Ich bin nah dran, aber weil sie alle Techniken benutzen, die wir gerade gesprochen haben,
fühlt sich das Website sehr schnell an. Es funktioniert sehr schnell.
Lüfter.
Der beste Radier.
Da ist er auch der Größte.
Ich habe meinen Smartphone mit einer Smartwatch
ersetzt.
Was haben wir das hier? Dieser 100 Euro.
Das ist doch garantiert wieder irgendein Mini-PC,
den sie hier an den Start haben und dann OpenSense
drauf klatschen oder so.
Oh, jetzt wird es tatsächlich
ein bisschen
spannender.
Wrt ist nice das übrigens auch was schon seit Ewigkeiten auf meiner Liste steht mein Unifax
ist Point umzurüsten mal und darauf zu testen wie Open wer läuft also ich weiß ja ich habe
keine Unifax ist points mehr also liegen eigentlich nur noch im Schrank und ich habe gelesen man kann
gerade auf die alten unify pro access points kann man auch ein wert drauf hauen einfach einfach mal
just verfahren ausprobieren wie man wie man das flaschen kann und was davon wie gut funzt
kein windows scheiß mehr sehr gut excellent windows windows weg
lief nicht stabil ich werde jetzt mal ausprobieren ich brauche die access
points ja ähnlich ich werde es einfach mal ausprobieren und checken wie das wie das funst
uns das noch mal ob wir t ist immer spannende sache hat chat gehen wenn ihr wenn ihr jetzt
jetzt hier vielleicht manche von euch öfters auch ein wrt benutzen haben die mittlerweile es geschafft
in das ui zu integrieren ihre nennen die das noch mal private pre chat key geschichte dynamic
pre shared key geschichte dass du quasi jedem wlan client oder jedem wlan endgerät ein eigenes
wlan passwort geben kannst können tun sie das ja schon seit einer weile haben es geschafft
das mittlerweile auch im UI zu integrieren, sodass du quasi ein WLAN-Passwort hast,
aber trotzdem noch bei Bedarf für jedes Gerät ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort vergeben kannst,
sodass du dann letztendlich, wenn du das Gerät wegschmeißt, nur dieses Passwort
entfernen musst und das wäre nice, wenn sie das endlich hingekriegt hätten.
Guck mal hier, das ist der OpenWrt1. Das ist ein komplett offener Router,
der nur 100 Euro kostet.
Und was heißt...
Guck mal hier, das ist der OpenWRT1.
Das ist ein...
Also wenn es ein selbst...
Nee, das ist kein 3D-gedrucktes Gehäuse
mit den Rippenrillen und so,
weil das wäre ja auch überhaupt nicht wärmeleitend.
Komplett offener Router, der nur...
Ja, oder doch?
Keine Ahnung.
100 Euro kostet.
Und was heißt offen?
Hard- und Software sind Open Source.
Ja, und was bringt das? Das bringt,
dass ihr mit der Kiste fast alles
machen könnt, was ihr wollen wollt.
Also auf jeden Fall deutlich.
Gut, ich meine, man muss dazu sagen, für 100 Euro
kriegt man auch schon irgendwelche günstigen
All-in-One
passiv gekühlten China
Dinger mit mehreren Ports
mit ein bisschen älteren
quasi, wie
nennt man das?
System on a Chip. So diese
Intel-Boards, die
die quasi aufgelötete CPU haben, wo man auch dann einfach OpenSense oder so drauf machen kann für den gleichen Preis.
Aber ich mag OpenWRT, deswegen gucken wir das jetzt trotzdem mal.
Mehr als mit normalen, kommerziellen Routern.
Ihr könnt aber nicht nur mehr konfigurieren, sondern ihr könnt da auch einfach Software drauf installieren.
Der zugehörige App Store hat fast 10.000 Softwarepakete drin.
Ich habe da zum Beispiel mit einem Mausklick AdKa-Pro mit.
die... Warum ist das jetzt...
Kann sein, auf
408p installiert.
Also auf dem Router. Ziemlich cool, oder?
Dass ich App Store jetzt gerade in
Anführungszeichen gesagt habe, das
liegt daran, dass das halt nur eine
lange Paketmanager-Liste ist.
Man muss also schon wissen, was man tut.
Also es gibt jetzt keine ausführlichen Beschreibungen
oder so. Und genau dieses
Wissen, was man tut, das ist der springende
Punkt beim OpenBRT1.
Die Lernkurve ist ziemlich
Ja, klar. Aber ich hatte da Bock drauf
und Profi-Netzwerker Adrian
hat mir auch gut geholfen bei meiner
OpenWrt-Reise. Und am Ende
hatten wir dann was richtig Cooles mit dem Ding
zusammengefrickelt. Also wirklich was,
was man auf jeden Fall... Ja, der ist ganz schön
teuer, was du da gepostet hast. Ich meine, das ist natürlich
ein fettes Teil, wenn ich mir das hier angucke.
Ist natürlich ein fettes
Ding. Ich sehe hier auch schon gleich
auf den ersten Blick zwei
SFP-Plus-Ports.
Das ist natürlich schon ein fettes Ding.
Auch
Speck-technisch,
allerdings auch Preis-technisch.
Das ist natürlich nicht ohne.
Also wenn man wirklich was
richtig Heftiges braucht,
ja, aber das ist wahrscheinlich
für 99,9% der Leute
massiver Overkill.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten Leute
müssen wirklich 10 Gigabit routen.
Die Leute müssen vielleicht 10 Gigabit switchen zu einem NAS oder so.
Aber wirklich Routen plus Firewall-Regeln dazwischen, so was, 10 Gig, das braucht eigentlich kaum einer.
NixOS, wir haben den NixOS Package Manager schon mal verwendet, aber NixOS selber noch nicht.
Ja, die MikroTik-Dinger sind nice.
Da habe ich ja auch ein paar hier.
... im handelsüblichen Router so nicht bewerkstelligen können.
Bleibt dran.
Lieber Herr Kahn.
Düt, düt, düt, düt.
Ja, das, was wir hier gleich in diesem Video machen,
also mehrere VPNs im Router-Vertrag.
Nord-VPN, ach ja.
Und die sponsern auch dieses Video.
Mit einem Nord-VPN-Account.
Ja, mein Video wollten sie nicht sponsern.
Könnt ihr zehn Geräte parallel...
Die Story habe ich schon oft genug erzählt.
...unterschiedliche VPNs bringen.
Okay, komm.
Also sie wollten, aber dann wollten sie nicht mehr, als sie gesehen haben, dass ich mich mal über VPN-Anbieter lustig gemacht habe.
Die haben gesagt, ich soll das Video löschen, wo ich mich über VPN-Anbieter lustig gemacht habe.
Nur dann kooperaten sie mit mir.
Habe ich ihnen gesagt, ich will aber das Video nicht löschen.
Und was heißt über VPN-Anbieter lustig gemacht? Ich habe mich nicht mehr über VPN-Anbieter lustig gemacht.
Ich habe halt gesagt, dass es zum größten Teil Schwachsinn ist, was da versprochen wird.
Und das mochte NordVPN nicht.
Die haben gesagt, nee Max, solange du das Video oben lässt, machen wir mit dir nix.
Nachdem sie schon gesagt haben, sie wollen was machen, die haben ja angefragt.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja gut, dann machen wir halt nix.
Das Offensichtliche, der Router heißt natürlich OpenWrt1, weil da OpenWrt draufgegriffen wird.
Und um zu erklären, was OpenWrt ist, muss ich einmal ein ganz bisschen ausholen, aber das ist wirklich eine interessante Geschichte.
Also, es war einmal ein Router, der Firma Linksys.
Der hieß WRT24.
Das ist der Klassiker schlechthin.
Ich wette mit euch, dass viele, die schon ein bisschen älter sind, dieses Ding mal hatten.
Das ist eines der Klassiker schlechthin.
50G. Das war 2002. Ja, und dessen integrierte Software nutzte einen veränderten Linux-Körnel. Das war zwar erlaubt, aber die zugrunde liegende Lizenz, die GNU-GPL, die erfordert, dass...
Please allow me to interject for a moment.
Moment, wo ist das passende Copy-Pasta-Chat?
Ich weiß den Befehl nicht mehr.
Ist es Ausrufezeichen Knu?
Nein, es ist Ausrufezeichen...
Moment, ich habe mich verschrieben.
Ah ja, okay.
Nice, perfekt.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Wir nennen es ja auch nicht Linux.
Wir nennen es ja Knu plus Linux.
sehr veränderte source code veröffentlicht wird ja und das hat links ist zuerst nicht gemacht aber
der monatelange druck aus der community hat die firma dann irgendwann reich gekocht und dann gab
es den source code also fast den komplett es gab ja es gab ja noch zwischenzeitlich die dwrt
openwerte dann gab es noch lede lede war glaube ich einen fork wie auch immer das ausspricht von
OpenWRT, die dann wieder
gemerged sind mit OpenWRT oder sowas.
Nur die Treiber
für den WLAN-Chipsatz.
Wie kann man einen YouTuber ernst nehmen, der für NordVPN
Werbung macht? Man darf Werbung nicht
mit den Leuten an sich vermischen.
Ich meine, ich war auch noch nie in einer Wüste,
falls sich jemand dran erinnert.
Und ich spiele trotzdem kein Genshin Impact.
Du musst das einfach sehen, wie es ist.
Es ist im Prinzip
so, wie wenn
Michael Schumacher für die deutsche Vermögensberatung
Werbung macht.
Dem geht das doch auch am Arsch vorbei.
Oder wen gibt's denn
denn sonst noch?
Guckt zu wenig Werbung.
Keine Ahnung.
Jedenfalls hatte die Open Source
Community dann Zugriff
auf eine komplette Router-Software.
Und die wird nun seitdem unter
dem Namen OpenWRT.
Ihr merkt WRT, WRT54,
sich, ne, nicknack, der Produktname
des Linksys-Router, immer weiter
entwickelt. Also seit über 20 Jahren.
Und zwar so, dass die Software auf
möglichst vielen unterschiedlichen Routern läuft.
Über 1800 Router-Modelle
werden inzwischen unterstützt.
Sind natürlich viele alte Gurken dabei,
aber auch viele, zumindest einigermaßen
moderne Modelle, zum Beispiel der
Asus TUF AX1000.
Was ich da mal ausprobieren will, ist
OpenWRT
Unify Pro
AP Pro
AC, AC, APAC
Pro.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Sieht ein bisschen komplizierter aus, was man da machen muss,
um das drauf zu kriegen.
Oder die Fritzbox
7530.
So, aber um OpenWrt
auf kommerzielle Router überhaupt aufzukriegen.
Das kann ziemlich pain in the ass sein.
Also ein bisschen fummelig und dann kann es auch passieren, dass es nicht für alle Features
des Routers Treiber gibt, denn funktionieren einige Sachen nicht.
Und deshalb gibt's jetzt die erste offizielle Hardware von OpenWrt, entwickelt von der OpenWrt
Community zusammen mit dem Hardwarehersteller BananaPy.
Okay, was ist denn da so am Start? Ein MediaTag, was auch immer, aber die Dinger sind relativ beliebt, das heißt, das ist okay so, kann man wahrscheinlich einfach so lassen und war für sie wahrscheinlich das naheliegendste.
ich blicke bei den Bezeichnungen nicht durch, aber diese Kombi gibt es oft
ok, WLAN Antennen
USB Stelz
was auch immer man den da benutzt
das Ding dürfte durchaus mal ein bisschen mehr
noch ein paar Ports mehr haben, wäre ganz praktisch, oder?
klar, die Mindestanzahl an Ports,
die du bei einem Router brauchst, sind zwei.
Okay, streng genommen kannst du natürlich einen Router
auch mit nur einem Port betreiben,
wenn du alles über WLANs machst.
Ja, das ist kein Ding, das funzt.
Aber sagen wir mal, vier Ports
wären trotzdem irgendwie ganz sinnig.
Kannst du dann sagen, okay, einmal was fürs interne Netz,
einmal was fürs externe, Richtung Mode im Internet,
was auch immer, vielleicht noch eins
fürs WLAN und noch eine DMZ
oder sowas, ja, also so vier Ports
sind schon ganz nice
ich hab keine Ahnung,
ob für diese Dinger da so ein
OpenWrt1
heißt das Ding und kannst zum Beispiel über
AliExpress... Ja gut, an den internen Port musst du ja dann eh
einen Switch dranhängen, du willst ja mehr als
einen Rechner dranhängen.
Aber um das
von der Verwaltung her zu vereinfachen,
sind vier Ports, finde ich, immer ganz
praktisch. Wie gesagt, internes Netz,
dahinter kommt ein Switch, du kannst ja dahinter alle anderen
auch einen Switch, du kannst mit vieler, was auch immer.
Aber du musst es gar nicht so kompliziert machen.
Vier Ports sind immer ganz gut. Du hast einen internen Port, du hast einen externen Port, du hast einen Port fürs WLAN und du hast einen Port für irgendwie noch was X, DMZ, irgendwas Shared-mäßiges oder sonst was. Vier Ports sind immer gut.
bestellt werden für ungefähr 100 Euro.
So als ich gerade geguckt habe, waren es ein paar Euro mehr.
Die Preise schwanken immer etwas.
Ja, und die Hardware ist durchaus brauchbar.
Also schnelles Wi-Fi 6, ein flotter ARM Dual-Core-Prozessor mit 1,3 GHz,
zwei Ethernet-Ports, leider nur einer davon mit 2,5 Gigabit, der andere hat nur 1 Gigabit
und für OpenWrt-Verhältnisse viel RAM, nämlich 1 Gigabyte.
Die Software würde auch mit 128 Megabytes zurechtkommen.
Das Ding ist also durchaus zukunftssicher.
Drei Sachen sind aber wirklich ungewöhnlich.
Erstens hat das Teil einen M.2-Slot für eine SSD.
Der ist mit PCI-Express 2.0 angebunden.
Möglich sind damit also 500 MBit pro Sekunde Brutto-Transferrate.
Das heißt, man steckt da einfach eine SSD rein und konfiguriert sich dann ein einfaches NAS.
Ist das überhaupt ein Board, wo eine SSD dran geht?
MKey?
Brutto-Transferrate.
Das heißt, man steckt da einfach eine SSD rein und konfiguriert sich dann ein einfaches NAS.
Und das haben wir auch ausprobiert und haben dafür große Dateien 150 MB schreibend und 170 MB lesend gemessen.
Das sind ziemlich gute Werte für so ein einfaches Router-NAS.
Also deutlich besser als viele andere kommerzielle Router mit so einer Funktion.
Was angekündigt ist, aber zurzeit noch nicht geht, es soll irgendwann möglich sein, auch von SSD direkt zu booten,
sodass man zum Beispiel echte Linux-Distributionen drauf starten kann.
Ist aber wie gesagt noch nicht fertig.
Die zweite ungewöhnliche Funktion ist der sogenannte Mikrobussockel.
Der ermöglicht über GPIO-Pins, also General Purpose Input Output, selbst gebastelte Hardware an den Router dran zu hängen.
Das ist ja cool, aber wie kriegst du die Software dann da drauf?
Zum Beispiel Sensoren oder so.
Das dritte ist, dass man das Teil nahezu unmöglich kaputtfrickeln kann.
Wenn man den Router irgendwie gebrickt hat, schaltet man einfach diesen Schalter hier hinten auf NOR und damit lässt sich der Router dann wieder reanimieren.
Neben dem 256 MB großen NAND-Flash-Speicher, auf dem das System installiert ist, gibt es nämlich noch einen schreibgeschützten 16 MB Flash-Chip, auf dem ist ein Bootloader gespeichert, der das Gerät im Notfall zurücksetzen kann.
Nice. Und auch ohne Notfallfunktion. Der Hooter lässt sich wirklich, also nicht übertrieben, in 5 Sekunden zurücksetzen.
Das heißt, man muss keine Angst haben beim Rumspielen. Wenn was nicht mehr geht, zack, wieder auf 0, alles easy.
Aber halt auf der Kommandozeile.
Ja gut. Ganz ehrlich, da würde ich jetzt auch mit nichts anderem, und ich will auch gar nichts anderes.
Also wenn ich mir so ein Bastelding kaufe, dann will ich da auch ordentlich Shell-Axes per SSH haben und rumbasteln können, wie ich denn, wie es mir beliebt, ja.
Ich muss dazu sagen, man muss beim OpenWare T1 wirklich Bock auf Frickeln haben.
Und man muss auch bedenken, da ist keinerlei Modem drin.
Das heißt, man braucht entweder einen zusätzlichen Router mit Modem oder halt ein separates Modem, was aber eher selten zu finden ist.
Und ich muss auch zugeben, als mein Netzwerkkollege Adrian mir von dem Ding erzählt hat, dachte ich so, ja krass, für 100 Euro ein Wi-Fi 6 Router, das ist ja super.
Da mache ich dann direkt ein Video.
Ich habe den OpenWare T1 als meinen Haupt-Alltags-Router getestet.
Ja, und dann Andrian aber so, nee, also für den Alltag ist das nix.
Das ist eher so ein Busterouter.
Und ich so, hä, was ist denn ein Busterouter?
Und das habe ich aber jetzt inzwischen einigermaßen verstanden.
Und ich versuche euch das in diesem Video auch jetzt mal ein bisschen näher zu bringen.
Schon als Veritase zu den Flores in SS7.
Nee.
Was ist denn SS7?
Ah, hier.
Okay, das ist irgendwas für Handys oder so.
Und dabei ist er...
28, du kannst das vorschlagen, je nachdem was es ist, aber ich glaube 28 schickst einfach.
Da ist dieser eine Punkt wirklich wichtig, dass man immer weiß, ich kann das Teil einfach komplett zurücksetzen.
Also ich kann da einfach drauf losfummeln, kann nichts passieren.
Also das finde ich psychologisch schon mal einen großen Vorteil bei der Kiste.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt auch mal, was ich mit der steilen Lernkurve am Anfang meinte.
Also ich habe den OpenWrt1 bei mir angeschlossen und ja, ich kam nicht auf die grafische Benutzeroberfläche,
obwohl ich die richtige IP-Adresse eingegeben habe.
stellte sich dann raus die grafische benutzeroberfläche von openwrt namens
luci ist da gar nicht drauf weil die routersoftware noch nicht als finales
release existiert sondern nur als sogenannte vorab snapshot version und da
ist dann halt kein luci vorinstalliert das heißt man muss per ssh also per
kommandozeile auf den router gehen und kann da dann luci manuell nach
installieren also mal nachgucken wie das geht mit luci in der offiziellen doku
Aha, okay, alles klar.
OPKG install Lucy.
Fehlermeldung.
Ja, es war ja APK ist es doch.
Okay, oh.
Stellt sich raus, seit kurzem ist nicht mehr OPKG als Paketmanager defaultmäßig vorinstalliert,
sondern das Ganze heißt APK.
Also APK install Lucy.
Nee, das geht nicht.
APK add.
Das heißt jetzt APK add Lucy.
Steht aber hier auf der offiziellen Supportseite halt nicht drauf.
musste ich selber herausfinden bzw. hat Andrian mir da auf die Sprüche geholfen.
Sobald es die OpenWare T1 Software als finales Release gibt,
wird Lucy natürlich auch vorinstalliert sein.
Das passiert dann nicht mehr.
Aber ich finde, diese Anekdote zeigt ganz anschaulich,
was mit Bustle Router gemeint ist.
Aber hat man Lucy nur installiert,
kann man sich halt über einen Browser in den Router einloggen.
Und ja, okay, das ist jetzt auch nicht ganz so einfach zu verstehen
wie so eine Fritzbox-Oberfläche.
Aber halt wirklich cool.
Wohl wahr, ja.
Hier zum Beispiel eben diesen Paketmanager,
von dem ja schon die Rede war.
Also unter System, Software kann ich dann einfach Sachen installieren.
Zum Beispiel Edgard Home zum Malware und Werbung.
Daniel, danke für den Sub.
Falls ihr nicht wisst, wozu das gut ist.
Wir haben schon mal ein Video über Pyhole gemacht.
Das ist im Prinzip das Gleiche wie Edgard Home.
So, aber generell ist das Ganze so ein bisschen spröde, würde ich sagen.
Aber grundlegende Sachen haben sich mir dann doch irgendwie selbst...
Ja klar, das ist für Leute, die Bastelstells wollen.
Ich meine, es ist ein bisschen damit zu vergleichen, ich habe ja drüben im Wohnzimmer auch einen DVB-C Empfänger mit Linux drauf und einem 8-fach Tuner drin.
Da komme ich auch per SSH drauf und ich kann per Kommandozeile Zeug starten, stoppen, nachinstallieren.
das ist so ähnlich, da musst du auch ein bisschen
Hang zum Basteln haben, aber dafür
kannst du es genau so
einrichten und am Ende
benutzen, wie du es haben willst
also
gibt da denke ich auch schon
eine
Abnehmer für sowas
erklärt hier zum Beispiel, wenn man
WLAN hinzufügen will, aussuchen
ob das 2,4 GHz oder
5 GHz sein soll.
Staubsauger mit SSH-Zugriff, beste.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob du das
jetzt einfach
nur sagst in Form von
sowas
abgedrehtes oder ob du dich dran erinnern
kannst, dass wir wirklich mal im Stream
einen Staubsauger mit SSH-Zugriff hatten.
Chat,
wer ist so lange dabei und erinnert sich noch
an den Staubsauger mit SSH-Zugriff?
Keiner mehr, oder?
Klar? Okay.
Wir hatten mal einen Staubsauger.
Ah, du hast aus, dass ihr Staubsauger...
Kann das sein, dass es...
dass die Suche buggt?
Ja, die Suche ist kaputt, oder?
Also die Suche hat seit gestern Probleme.
Okay, dann...
Ja, dann machen wir da nichts.
Stopp, sorry.
SSH-Face, alles klar.
auf
ESSID, den gewünschten Namen.
Ah, hier muss ich mal kurz gucken. Was kannst du alles anstellen?
Dann auf Add.
Dann hier auf ESSID.
Äh, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kurz was gucken.
Nee, das sind nur die Defaults-Sachen.
Der Ultras.
Ja, gut.
ESSID, den gewünschten Namen.
Advanced Settings. Ich hoffe, der klickt noch auf Advanced Settings.
Namen eingeben bei Channel hier oben.
Vielleicht auf Auto, wenn ihr keinen eigenen Channel vorgeben wollt.
Dann unter Wireless...
Hallo.
Setting.
Unter Wireless Security die Verschlüsselung auswählen, zum Beispiel WP.
... PA3, da dann unter Key das gewünschte Passwort und dann am Ende hier...
Haben die das schon im WLAN?
Haben die das da schon drin, dass man pro Gerät Passwörter vergeben kann?
Können kann das OpenWRT schon eine Weile.
Ich frage mich, ob das im Webinterface schon drin ist.
... auf Save & Apply.
Ich sehe jetzt nichts dazu.
Das unterscheidet sich jetzt erstmal nicht so grundlegend von normalen Routern, aber
mit OpenWrt kann ich zum Beispiel ganz viele WLANs anlegen.
Bei normalen Routern gibt's oft maximal ein Gast-WLAN, aber da hört's dann schon auf.
Mit OpenWrt sind mir da keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Guck mal hier, so sieht das bei mir gerade aus, also 6 WLANs.
Ja, macht das mal mit eurem normalen Router.
Jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich, ja gut, abgeschottetes Gast-WLAN verstehe ich, aber
wozu braucht man denn noch mehr WLAN?
Ich hab schon öfters WLANs gebraucht, zum Beispiel zum rumbasteln oder für den Stream oder so, dass ich aus Versehen mal das Passwort leaken kann.
Da hatte ich dann tatsächlich einen echten Anwendungsfall. Ich wollte nämlich auf einem Notebook dieses umstrittene Microsoft-Feature Windows Recall installieren, aber das war zu dem Zeitpunkt in der Dev-Version noch USA-only.
Das wurde offenbar in Deutschland noch nicht ausgeliefert.
Und das klappte auch nicht, wenn ich mich auf dem Notebook selbst per VPN in die USA getunnelt habe.
Deshalb wollte ich es mal mit einer komplett zurückgesetzten Windows-Installation versuchen,
deren erster Kontakt mit dem Internet direkt, ja, ein amerikanischer ist.
Und das geht halt, indem sich der Router in die USA tunnelt
und sich der Windows-Rechner dann halt direkt mit dem Router verbindet
und dann direkt quasi virtuell in den USA ist.
also gar keine Berührung mit einer deutschen IP-Adresse hatte.
Und das funktioniert zum Beispiel mit einer Fritzbox und meinem VPN-Anbieter so nicht,
weil die Fritzbox nur IPsec und WireGuard unterstützt, meinen VPN-Anbieter aber beides nicht.
OpenWrt kann OpenVPN und das kann halt auch mein VPN-Anbieter
und das habe ich dann in OpenWrt konfiguriert, also mit Login-Passwort und so weiter
und zack konnte ich dann auf dem Notebook tatsächlich Windows Recall installieren.
Und dann dachte ich mir, wie cool wäre das denn, wenn der Router gleich mehrere WLANs aufspannen würde und jedes wäre in ein anderes Land getunnelt.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee, wenn man dafür einen Anwendungszweck hat.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel mit meinem Fernseher immer in andere WLANs einwähle.
Ja, eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Um dann unterschiedliche Sachen bei den...
Ich meine, das kann man auch anderweitig lösen.
Aber wenn man das WLAN-Gerät hat...
Ich meine, okay, ich würde es wahrscheinlich so machen.
Lass mal überlegen.
Angenommen, ich hätte hier irgendwie die Notwendigkeit dafür,
sagen wir mal, ich hätte eine Streamingbox
und ich möchte, dass die immer über einen VPN in, keine Ahnung, Indien geht.
Und ich hätte eine zweite Streamingbox, wo ich will,
dass die immer über einen VPN in den USA geht.
Da würde ich wahrscheinlich, also das erste, was mir so einfällt, ist,
ich verteile unterschiedliche Gateway-IPs per DHCP.
Die kommen ins gleiche WLAN rein, wie alle anderen Geräte auch,
DAF-Media-Geräte, und per DHCP verteile ich unterschiedliche Gateway-IPs.
IPs.
Oder?
Das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Und
dahinter
muss dann halt der
Router so eingestellt sein, dass
was dort reingeht,
oder was diese Gateway IP verwendet,
das ist halt das
USA-VPA. Das klingt mir erst einmal
am naheliegendsten. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es so
einfach ist, wie ich mir vorstelle.
Aber es müsste eigentlich funktionieren.
Meine Sicherungskopien.
Immer Sicherungskopien.
Max, in den USA gibt es in zwei Tagen einen validen Grund, NordVPN zu kaufen.
Die Hälfte der Bundesstaaten wird Pornhub blockiert.
Wirklich?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Battle Sheep, kannst du ja nachher gucken.
Ich weiß nicht, wie oft es in nächster Zeit welche gibt.
Ich muss noch ein paar Sachen fixen, real life technisch dann.
Ich bin wieder am Start.
Einen Streaming-Anbieter zu sehen, das ist ja je nach Land unterschiedlich.
Okay, sag ich jetzt. Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen spezialistmäßig,
aber VPNs direkt im Router zu verdrahten, das hat ja noch andere Vorteile.
zum Beispiel, dass man damit Geräte ins VPN holen kann, auf denen man eigentlich keinen VPN-Client
installieren kann. Wie schon gesagt, zum Beispiel Fernseher oder eine Nintendo Switch zum Beispiel
oder halt beliebige andere WLAN-Geräte. Und ich finde es tatsächlich auch einigermaßen elegant,
dass man, wenn man mal ein VPN nutzen will, einfach in das entsprechende WLAN reingeht. Man braucht
dann halt keine Client-Software installieren und auch nichts pro Gerät konfigurieren,
oder macht man halt einmal auf dem Router und fertig.
Wenn euch das jetzt noch nicht überzeugt hat,
dann habe ich auch noch eine andere coole Sache,
die mit normalen Routern so nicht möglich
oder nur sehr schwierig möglich wäre,
nämlich die Reiserouter-Software Travelmate.
Wer von euch viel reist,
kennt ja vermutlich so nervige Hotel-WLANs,
wo man immer irgendwelche Captive-Portale anklicken muss
oder nur ein einziges WLAN-Gerät nutzen darf.
Mit dem OpenWare T1 regelt dann die Travelmate-Software
den Uplink zum Hotel-WLAN
und macht dann für euch ein eigenes privates WLAN aus, wo ihr dann beliebige Geräte reinhängen könnt.
Und voilà, kein Gefruckel mehr mit irgendwelchen Captive-Dingern und begrenzter Gerätezahl.
Mein Fass.
Das ist praktisch, wenn man sowas braucht.
Der OpenWare T1 ist kein Alltagsrouter.
Das wird der auch nie werden, alleine weil da kein Modem eingebaut ist.
Aber wenn ihr Lust auf etwas wildere Netzwerkbasteleien habt, wie meine VPN.
Das ist auch eine komische Kombination, oder? Ein Gigabit-Port?
Und einen 2,5G. Ist mit PoE gemeint, dass der Port selbst Geräte per PoE speisen kann?
Oder ist mit PoE gemeint, er kann selbst Strom bekommen über PoE?
Ich würde vermuten, er kann selbst Strom bekommen über PoE.
Selbst wird er kein PoE können, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Er kann bekommen, okay, ja.
Also quasi POI-In, wenn man es mal so nennen mag.
Wenn ihr meine VPN-WLANs oder das Ding eben als Reiserouter nutzen wollt,
dann könnte das Ding für euch ziemlich praktisch sein.
Ist halt so ein Schweizer Netzwerk-Taschenmesser,
mit dem ihr so abseitige Netzwerksachen machen könnt.
Wollt ihr einfach nur einen Router, der eure Geräte schnell und zuverlässig ins Netz bringt,
dann ist das wahrscheinlich nichts für euch.
Aber trotzdem ein cooles Ding.
Irgendwie, das gefällt mir.
Ich meine, ich bestelle mir jetzt kein...
In dem Moment, wo ich es ausgesprochen habe,
habe ich mir tatsächlich überlegt.
Nee, nee.
Ich bestelle mir keinen.
Aber ich finde, es ist ein cooles Gerät.
Nee, was soll ich damit?
Ich habe wirklich gar keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Es wäre einfach nur ein bisschen zum Just-for-Fun-Rumbasteln.
The Dramatic History of Twisted Pair.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Netzwerkkabel eine dramatische Geschichte haben.
Ist das vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, der Titel?
Geschichte,
wo er jetzt wegkam.
Das gucken wir in den
28 Minuten, das ist mir ein bisschen zu übertrieben
lang, aber
die dramatische
Geschichte.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Sechs Dinge, die sich 2025
ändern. Boah, das ist wahrscheinlich wieder
mehr Bürokratie und mehr Abfuck.
2024 endet mit einer Änderung.
Die Bundestagswahl im kommenden Jahr wird nicht erst im September stattfinden,
wie eigentlich geplant, sondern schon im Februar.
Anfang November 2024 wurden dafür die Weichen gestellt,
nachdem die FDP aus der Ampelkoalition ausgeschieden ist.
Und inzwischen wurden alle für...
Ich kann jetzt ja noch nicht mal mehr die FDP wählen, weil die haben ja gar keine Aussichten, irgendwas zu reißen.
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat im Bundestag die Vertrauensfrage gestellt, wie gewünscht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich wähle.
Und Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier hat daraufhin eine Auflösung des Bundestags plus Neuwahl festgelegt, nämlich am 23. Februar 2025.
Das ist sicher eine der wichtigsten Änderungen im kommenden Jahr.
Es gibt aber auch noch mehr. Zum Beispiel zusätzliches Geld. Zumindest für einige. Aber auch höhere Kosten. Leider für alle.
Außerdem eine neue Regelung für Reisen nach Großbritannien und eine kleine Revolution bei der Post.
Das war es jetzt. Und sehr empfehlen kann ich euch außerdem auch dieses Video hier oben auf dem i.
Es gibt jetzt neue Faxgeräte oder?
Kollegen von Simplicissimus, die auch etwas Spannendes zum Jahreswechsel für euch am Start haben. Also schaut da auf jeden Fall rein.
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk
Ganz ehrlich, die schwierigste Umstellung zum Jahreswechsel
ist für mich immer, dass man überall eine neue Jahreszahl hinschreiben muss.
Es klingt banal, aber es dauert bei mir immer bis Februar oder März,
bis im Kopf sich alles umgestellt hat.
Ist aber natürlich mein persönliches Problem,
andere Änderungen betreffen uns alle.
Und genau die schauen wir uns in diesem Video etwas genauer an.
Ich bin nur auf das Zweite.
In der Infobox findet ihr aber noch einige.
Und traditionell mit dem ersten Punkt.
Wir versuchen es optimistisch.
Es geht ums Finanzielle.
Erstens, es gibt mehr Geld.
Starten wir mit dem Mindestlohn.
Die sogenannte Mindestlohnkommission,
die aus Vertretern für Arbeitnehmer, Arbeitgeber und Wissenschaft besteht,
hat festgelegt, 2025...
Jetzt gibt es jetzt 30 Cent mehr, oder was?
...steigt der gesetzliche Mindestlohn auf 12,82 Euro pro Stunde.
Von?
Das sind 41 Cent mehr als...
Boah!
Jetzt aber vorbei, ey.
In Saus und Braus wird jetzt da gelebt.
Bisher.
Weiterhin gilt allerdings, in bestimmten Bereichen greift der Mindestlohn nicht.
Krass, 41 Cent.
Und auch in der Ausbildung.
Für die Ausbildung gibt es einen Extramindestlohn.
Das ist die sogenannte Mindest...
Einfach Armut komplett zerstört mit 41 Cent.
...ist Ausbildungsvergütung.
Und auch die steigt 2025...
Oh, das ist natürlich ganz gut.
Das ist die sogenannte Mindestausbildungsvergütung.
Und auch die steigt 2025 im ersten Lehrjahr auf mindestens 682 Euro pro Monat, im zweiten Jahr auf mindestens 805 Euro und im dritten Jahr dann auf 921 Euro mindestens.
Allerdings gilt das nur für Azubis, die 2025 ihre Ausbildung angefangen haben.
Und natürlich können einzelne Branchen oder Betriebe auch mehr bezahlen.
Alter, kriegen Azubis mittlerweile viel Geld?
Gut, ich meine, nein, kriegen sie nicht.
Ich vergleiche das nur mit meinem Azubi-Gehalt.
Das Ding ist halt nur, bei mir ist es schon ewig her.
Das kann man nicht wirklich vergleichen.
Dass der Mindestlohn steigt, hat auch Auswirkungen auf die Obergrenze bei Minijobs.
Statt wie bisher 538 Euro kann man künftig 556 Euro pro Monat verdienen.
Aufs Jahr gerechnet sind das immerhin mehr als...
Was?
...künftig auf die Obergrenze bei Minijobs.
Ach so.
Statt wie bisher 538 Euro kann man künftig 556 Euro pro Monat verdienen.
Aufs Jahr gerechnet sind das immerhin mehr...
Wurde es noch härter ausgebeutet.
Ja, die Opa-Logik ist jetzt ja, weil ich krass ausgebeutet wurde, will ich, dass alle heute auch krass ausgebeutet werden.
Nee, bei mir war das so, ich glaube, wenn man das wahrscheinlich mal inflationsbereinigt rechnet, wahrscheinlich habe ich auch gar nicht so viel weniger gekriegt.
...mehr als 200 Euro zusätzlich, wenn man die Grenzen komplett ausreizt.
Mehr Geld gibt es außerdem, zumindest für einige, wenn 2025 eine Steuerreform greift.
Vor allem diejenigen mit niedrigem oder mittlerem Einkommen könnten dadurch entlastet werden.
Es würde mehr Netto vom Brutto bleiben.
Da zähle ich leider, leider. Das wird sich wahrscheinlich nicht betreffen.
Ich hätte auch kein Problem mehr Netto rauszugeben.
Das habe ich unten in der Infobox verlinkt.
Eine Rolle spielt dabei auch, dass der Grundfreibetrag angehoben wird um 312 Euro im Jahr auf 12.096 Euro.
Dieser Betrag gilt als Existenzminimum, deshalb werden darauf keine Steuern fällig.
Und auch die Renten werden 2025 steigen. Um welchen Prozentsatz genau, das steht allerdings noch nicht fest.
Und damit kommen wir zum nächsten und weniger erfreulichen Punkt.
Zweitens, es wird teurer.
Zunächst mal muss man festhalten, da hätte ich auch so drauf getippt.
Es wurde auch schon teurer. Auch 2024 war ein Jahr der Preisanstiege.
Zum Beispiel in Restaurants.
Es wird eigentlich prinzipiell immer teurer. Zumindest in Zahlen.
Ja, wie man das, ob das natürlich dann real wirklich so ist. Was ich auch geil fand, ich habe letztens in irgendeinem Radiobericht gehört, die Inflationsrate wäre etwas gesunken und da wurde dann gesagt, ja, ob jetzt die Preise wieder sinken. Da habe ich auch gedacht, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Das Einzige, was das sagt, ist, dass die Preise vielleicht nicht mehr so stark steigen. Mit sinken hat das nichts zu tun.
Mehrwertsteuersatz in der Gastronomie für Leistungen vor Ort wieder auf 19% angehoben worden ist,
wurden fast überall die Preise in den Speisekarten angepasst.
Nach oben logischerweise.
Die Folge ist...
Soll ich euch mal sagen, ratet mal, ich habe zu Weihnachten was zu essen bestellt.
Also vorbestellt bei einem Restaurant.
Ich habe bei einem Restaurant vorbestellt Gänsebraten für vier Personen.
Mit Rotkohl und Knödel.
So ein Klassiker zu Weihnachten.
Für vier Personen.
Ratet mal, was ich bezahlt habe.
Ziemlich, Alter, ziemlich gut.
Ja, nee, nee, er hat recht.
Er hat recht, ziemlich genau 120 Euro.
125, glaube ich, waren es, 125.
Ja, ziemlich gut, gut geschätzt, ja.
... ist seit Januar noch teurer geworden.
Ich finde auch, dass es geht.
Find ich auch. Ja, find ich auch.
Inflationsrate pendelt sich zwar momentan wieder bei um die 2% ein,
aber die sehr hohen Raten 2022 und 2023 machen sich immer noch bemerkbar.
Vor allem bei Lebensmitteln.
Im Vergleich zum Jahr 2020 kostet Quark heute 73% mehr.
Zucker 83%.
Und das neue flüssige Gold scheint Olivenöl zu sein.
Dachte Dubai Schokolade.
Mit einem Preisanstieg von 113%.
Beim Öl hängt es aber weniger an der Inflation, sondern mehr an schlechten Bedingungen im für Deutschland wichtigsten Erzeugerland Spanien.
Aber egal woran es liegt, klar ist, beim Einkaufen fallen diese Preiserhöhungen auf.
Und uns wird künftig noch etwas auffallen.
Nehmen wir mal Benzin und Diesel.
Durch die automatisch ansteigende CO2-Steuer erhöht sich auch der Preis für Sprit.
Der Lobbyverband ADAC geht davon aus, dass Diesel und Benzin 2025 im Durchschnitt mindestens 3 Cent pro Liter teurer sein werden.
Andere Berechnungen gehen von mindestens 4 Cent aus.
Klar ist auf jeden Fall, die aktuellen Spritpreise werden wohl nicht zu halten sein.
Und wo wir gerade beim Auto sind, auch die Versicherung für Fahrzeuge könnte deutlich teurer werden.
Je nach den Voraussetzungen, die für euch gelten, weil das sehr individuell ist, habe ich euch dazu etwas in der Infobox verlinkt.
Das gilt übrigens auch für andere Versicherungen. Auch dort gibt es viele Anstiege.
Teurer wird es auch bei der Kranken- und Pflegeversicherung.
In beiden Fällen steigt der prozentuale Anteil der Sätze.
Das bedeutet, dass am Ende weniger vom Gehalt übrig bleibt
und dass auch Arbeitgeber mehr bezahlen müssen.
Außerdem steigen ...
Endlich noch mehr für Scheißbehandlung bezahlen!
Und Ärzte, die keinen Bock auf mich haben.
... die Beitragsbemessungsgrenzen.
Das wiederum heißt, dass alle, die besonders viel Geld verdienen,
künftig noch mehr Sozialabgaben leisten müssen ...
Jawoll!
... als bisher.
Ich kann's kaum erwarten.
Deutschland-Ticket nutzen. Also endlich,
endlich noch mehr Kohle abdrücken.
Richtig geil.
Und nix davon
irgendwie
in was gesteckt sehen, was ja wichtig ist.
Da hab ich da. Endlich. Endlich.
Dieses Nahverkehrsticket, das überall
im Land eingesetzt werden kann.
Bisher hat das 49 Euro pro Monat gekostet.
Künftig werden das 58 Euro
sein. Ja gut. Aufs Jahr gesehen.
Das find ich auch okay.
Ganz ehrlich, das könnte
sogar 69 Euro kosten.
Das fände ich okay.
Es ist tatsächlich immer noch günstiger als diese Kack-RMV-Monats-Tickets früher.
Und es macht einfach dieses Ticket-Chaos weg in Deutschland.
Ich kann mich einfach in Zug setzen und nach Bayern irgendwie runterfahren oder so.
Gut, das würde ich jetzt gar nicht mal so plakativ sagen.
Das hier ist was, was du freiwillig entscheidest.
Das ist was, wozu du gezwungen wirst.
Das ist ja schon mal ein prinzipieller Unterschied.
Euro zusätzlich.
Und auch die Preise für den Fernverkehr bei der Bahn steigen.
Also 69 Euro.
Warum sind wir in Deutschland,
beziehungsweise generell auf Deutsch,
eigentlich so ein Fan von Zahlen verkehrt
darum sagen. Warum sagen
wir nicht auch 6, 9,
sondern sagen 69?
Das ist so dumm.
69 ist viel besser als 69.
Warum
sagen wir das falsch rum? Egal,
ich würde mir auch für 69
Euro ein Ticket kaufen, wenn der
Fernverkehr drin ist.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Also ohne Scheiß, das
Deutschland-Ticket ist eines der besten Sachen, die sie
in den letzten Jahren auf die Reihe bekommen haben.
deswegen finde ich diskussion darüber das müssen wir abschaffen die da von
manchen seiten kommen schon wieder absolut lächerlich unter anderem hier
von der linken oberen ecke kommt das ja
ich habe ich habe wirklich absolut keine hast du mal gesehen die franzosen ihre
zahlen struktur rené keine ahnung und so sich habe ich kann ich weiß nur dass
sie gerne mal autos anzünden
ein Video von Art dazu, okay.
Ich hab, ich hab immer noch, also wirklich, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, wen ich nächstes Jahr wählen sollte.
Ähm, die letzten Jahre hab ich tatsächlich öfters FDP gewählt.
Das kam im Wahl-O-Mat bei mir auch immer oben raus.
Aber die haben ja wirklich gar keine Aussichten, irgendwas zu reißen diesmal.
Die Grünen will ich aus zwei Gründen nicht.
Und das liegt unter anderem an solchen Sachen wie Trusted Flagger.
und wir verklagen Leute,
die sich auf Twitter aufregen.
Beides komplettes Unding für mich.
In SPD und CDU
habe ich überhaupt kein Vertrauen, dass sie irgendwas auf die Reihe
kriegen.
Also ich habe echt keine Ahnung.
Wir machen wieder den Valomar zusammen.
Bleibt noch die AfD.
Ja.
Wobei ich mir bei denen halt absolut nicht sicher bin,
ob die irgendwas auf die Reihe kriegen,
Weil das Hauptsächliche, was ich von der AfD höre, ist, es sind alle böse zu uns.
Und was die auch gut, sagen wir mal, gut breit treten können, weil das ja auch an vielen Stellen passiert.
So nach dem Motto, wird nicht eingeladen, wird nicht über Themen, das können die halt schon.
Aber wenn die wirklich mal in der Position sind, was machen zu müssen, da habe ich auch meine Zweifel, ob die das auf die Reihe kriegen.
Deswegen bin ich schon lange der Meinung, und da stehe ich wahrscheinlich relativ alleine da, dass es gar nicht so verkehrt wäre, wenn zumindest mal auf niedrigerer Ebene die AfD mit dabei wäre.
Einfach, dass man mal sehen kann, ob denn hinter dem Geschwätz was dahinter ist.
Weil man kann immer sich schön hinsetzen und sagen, wir werden ja nie eingeladen, wir würden das alles besser machen, wenn man nie zeigen muss, dass man es besser machen könnte.
Kann man sich immer noch darauf zurückziehen.
Deswegen fände ich es gar nicht so schlecht, wenn die mal in der Position wären, dass sie das zeigen müssten.
Und dann würde man auch sehen, wahrscheinlich kriegen sie es auch nicht hin, sondern labern nur.
Weil aktuell sind sie in der komfortablen Position, zu sagen, ey, wir würden das alles besser machen, ohne dass sie jemals beweisen müssen, dass sie es besser könnten.
Ja, und deswegen
Wäre das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so verkehrt
Letztendlich früher oder später wird es eh passieren
Ja, das denke ich mir nämlich auch
Weil das ist das, wo sie wirklich gut sind zur Zeit drin
Also zu sagen, wir werden überall benachteiligt
Und wir würden das alles viel besser machen
Aber wenn man das nie beweisen muss
Kann man das auch wunderbar
deswegen wäre das vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht
wenn sie es mal zeigen müssten
und es gibt ja genug Bundesländer
da haben sehr viele Leute sich dafür entschieden
eben die AfD zu wählen
das heißt da gibt es eine gewisse Zustimmung auch
und dann frage ich mich halt
ob diese Zustimmung immer noch so hoch ist
wenn sie mal in der Verantwortung wären
und man sieht sie kriegen es auch nicht geschissen
Ja, das würde mich echt interessieren, was dann passieren würde, wenn man sieht, okay, die kriegen es genauso wenig hin, sind zwar immer groß am meckern drüber, das ist von den, wie nennen sie das immer, die haben doch so ein Spezialwort dafür für etablierte Parteien, es fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein, dass sie es genauso wenig geschissen bekommen.
Ne, ne, die sagen nicht Altparteien, die haben nur so ein Spezialwort dafür.
Die Bayern wählen seit 50 Jahren CSU.
Kartellparteien sagen die immer, genau.
Ja, das ist das Wort, was ich gesucht habe.
Deswegen fände ich es gar nicht so schlecht, wenn die auch mal zeigen müssten
und nicht nur labern könnten.
und insofern
wäre das vielleicht gar nicht mal verkehrt
wenn man sehen würde, die kriegen es auch nicht gebacken
doch doch, das sagen die gerne
Kartellparteien ist so eines der Lieblingswörter
also ich habe wirklich gesagt
keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll
letzten Jahre war es hauptsächlich die FDP
aber die haben überhaupt keine Aussichten
mehr irgendwas geschissen zu bekommen
Gucken wir mal weiter.
... in verschiedenen Bereichen an.
Dazu vermuten Experten, dass die Energiepreise weiter ansteigen könnten, vor allem die fürs Gas.
Da kann es sich lohnen, Anbieter zu vergleichen und auch immer mal wieder zu wechseln.
Das gleiche gilt für Strom.
Wobei es auch Regionen in Deutschland geben kann, je nach Anbieter, in denen die Preise sinken.
Und der Vollständigkeit halber noch eine Info.
In einigen Branchen wurden über die Tarifverträge...
Ihr dürft nicht vergessen, der Markt regelt das, ja?
deutliche Lohnerhöhungen durchgesetzt.
Davon profitieren natürlich alle, die dort angestellt sind, ganz klar.
Aber gleichzeitig könnte das auch dazu führen,
dass die Preise für bestimmte Dienstleistungen weiter ansteigen.
Höhere Preise gibt es außerdem auch bei der Post.
Und damit sind wir bei drittens, das neue Postgesetz.
Zum 1. Januar 2025 tritt das sogenannte Gesetz
zur Modernisierung des Postrechts in Kraft.
Das einerseits interne Dinge anders regelt,
andererseits aber auch Angelegenheiten,
die uns als Kunden ganz direkt betreffen.
Man könnte fast von einer kleinen Revolution sprechen,
weil die Änderungen sehr umfangreich sind.
Das Wichtigste ist erstens, für fast alle Briefe, 95% insgesamt, gilt,
sie dürfen drei Tage unterwegs sein statt bisher zwei.
Das heißt, wenn man ganz eilige Fristsachen hat, zum Beispiel Bewerbungen,
warum machen wir es absichtlich schlechter?
Dann muss man etwas mehr Zeit für den Versand einplanen oder den teureren Expressversand auswählen.
Zweitens...
Was soll denn Mist?
...Gäste mit einem Gewicht von mehr als 10 Kilogramm bis 20 Kilogramm und über 20 Kilo müssen künftig mit einem gut sichtbaren Hinweis gekennzeichnet sein, dass sie schwer sind.
Das soll vor allem den Mitarbeitern im Paketversand das Leben ein bisschen einfacher machen, weil sie direkt...
Moment, das muss ich mir nochmal anhören, was?
...über 20 Kilo müssen künftig mit einem gut...
Wenn man zu frist Sachen hat, zum Beispiel Bewerbungen, dann muss man etwas mehr Zeit für den Versand einplanen oder den teureren Expressversand auswählen.
Zweitens, Pakete mit einem Gewicht von mehr als 10 Kilogramm bis 20 Kilogramm und über 20 Kilo müssen künftig mit einem gut sichtbaren Hinweis gekennzeichnet sein, dass sie schwer sind.
Das soll vor allem den Mitarbeitern im Paketversand das Leben ein bisschen einfacher machen, weil sie direkt sehen, oha, schweres Paket.
Immerhin, bei Privatkunden übernimmt die jeweilige Filiale.
Die merken das auch.
Schweres Paket.
Das ist der Hinweis, es sei denn, ihr seid in einer Packstation.
In diesem Zusammenhang führt die Post auch einen neuen Tarif für den Versand von Paketen
zwischen 10 und 20 Kilo ein, der um einen Euro günstiger ist als bisher.
Dafür zieht der Preis für Pakete zwischen 20 und 30 Kilo deutlich an, von knapp 20 auf
knapp 24 Euro.
Das ist zum Beispiel relevant, wenn ihr irgendwo etwas bestellt, wo ihr die Versandkosten selbst
übernehmen müsst.
Und drittens, das Porto für Briefe wird teurer.
Gleich mal Zement bei Amazon bestellen. Ich habe mal Autoreifen bestellt bei Amazon. Das war auf jeden Fall über 10 Kilo.
Standardbrief kostet zum Beispiel 2025 95 Cent. Das sind 10 Cent mehr als bisher und es ist nah dran an einem Euro, den wir dann 2027 erreichen könnten.
2026 müssen die Preise noch unverändert bleiben.
Und von der Post kommen wir zu viertens das Auto.
Dass die Preise für Kfz-Versicherungen ansteigen können, das haben wir ja gerade eben schon gehört.
Es gibt aber auch noch einige andere Änderungen, die mit dem Auto zu tun haben.
Einige Führerscheine laufen zum Beispiel ab und müssen erneuert werden.
Vielleicht kennt ihr von euren Eltern und Großeltern noch diese alten Führerscheine aus Papier.
Lappen werden die auch genannt, völlig zu Recht, weil sie wirklich ziemlich lapprig sind.
Und die werden ab 2025 noch seltener.
Denn bis zum 19. Januar 2025 müssen alle Jahrgänge ab 1971, die noch so ein Ding haben, zum Umtausch.
Ich glaube, meine Mutter hat so ein Teil noch.
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Der natürlich Geld kostet.
Nur noch die vor 1953 geborenen Menschen
dürfen weiterhin mit einem Papierführerschein...
Moment.
Äh.
Wann ist meine Mutter geboren?
Die ist jetzt 74.
Das heißt, sie ist 1950 geboren.
Ja, die darf ihren Papierführerschein behalten.
Okay.
Ja, dann freut sie sich bestimmt.
...schein unterwegs sein.
Also gebt in euren Familien-Chatgruppen lieber mal allen Bescheid. Und dazu schreiben könnt ihr dann außerdem noch...
liegen dann irgendwelche ausgeschnittenen Sternchen oder irgendwelches Glitzerzeug oder sonst was.
Und wenn du da aus irgendeiner Dose was rausholen willst,
dann musst du erstmal eine halbe Stunde das Zeug runtersortieren und danach wieder drauf sortieren.
Das ist so abfucknervig. Warum? Das ist so unpraktisch.
Aber gut.
Wenn es ihr gefällt, sollen sie es machen. Das ist ihre Küche.
Das Winter- und Ganzjahresreifen, auf denen nur M plus S steht,
nicht mehr genutzt werden dürfen, wenn es glatt ist.
Die Reifen müssen das Alpine-Symbol haben.
Was? Moment, was? Wie, wo?
Weiterhin mit einem Papierführerschein unterwegs sein.
Also gebt in euren Familien-Chatgruppen lieber allen Bescheid.
Dazu könnt ihr außerdem noch das Winter- und Ganzjahresreifen,
auf denen nur M plus ...
Ja, Moment, ich hab Ganzjahresreifen.
Hab ich.
Weil ich zu faul bin.
... steht, nicht mehr genutzt werden dürfen, wenn es glatt ist.
Die Reifen müssen das Alpine-Symbol haben, das so aussieht.
Das kontrolliert doch eh keiner.
Hat man das nicht, dann droht nicht nur eine Strafe, sondern bei Unfällen zahlt die Versicherung nicht.
Oh, das ist schlecht. Habe ich ein Alpine-Symbol drauf? Das muss ich mal nachgucken.
Ich habe absolut keinen Plan, was ich für Reifen drauf habe.
Diese Regelung gilt sogar schon seit Oktober.
Ich meine, meine Reifen sind zwei Jahre alt. Die sollten das haben, hoffentlich.
Ja.
Toba 2024.
Und falls ihr mit dem Gedanken spielt, euch 2025 ein neues Auto zu kaufen, dann solltet ihr wissen...
Okay, dann haben sie es auf jeden Fall. Nice.
Preise könnten eventuell steigen.
Denn die deutschen Autobauer sind in der Krise.
Immer weniger Absatz sorgt für sinkenden Umsatz.
Das könnte unter Umständen dazu führen, dass versucht wird, über Preiserhöhungen wieder mehr Geld reinzuholen.
Eine Ausnahme könnten allerdings Elektroautos sein.
Und logischerweise Autos anderer Anbieter aus anderen Ländern.
Wisst ihr, eine Sache, ich habe mir selbst ein Elektroauto gekauft vor zwei Jahren, eine Sache, die dort schon wieder übertrieben dämlich geregelt war, es gab ja, vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch, es gab ja eine Prämie für Elektroautos, weiß gar nicht mehr, wie viel das war, aber es war schon nicht schlecht, es hat sicherlich viele Leute dazu gebracht, darüber nachzudenken, sich ein Elektroauto zu kaufen, unter anderem mich, weiß ich nicht, was war, 4000 Euro, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, keine Ahnung, es war auf jeden Fall ganz, 4500 oder so,
Es war auf jeden Fall ordentlich.
Zumindest war das Problem mit dieser Prämie,
du hast sie nur bis Ende des Jahres bekommen.
Und entscheidend war dafür nicht etwa das Kaufen des Autos,
sondern das Bekommen des Autos.
Und gerade vor zwei Jahren hatten Elektroautos relativ lange Lieferzeit.
Das heißt, wenn du dein Auto Mitte 2022 bestellt hast und es allerdings dann erst 2023 ausgeliefert wurde, hast du nicht mehr die Prämie bekommen von 2022.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich nicht verstanden habe. Warum hat man da nicht gesagt, okay, mit dem Unterschrift des Kaufvertrages quasi oder mit dem Eingehen des Kaufvertrages,
bekommt man die Prämie, die in diesem Jahr gilt.
Das hätte sicherlich dazu geführt, dass noch einige Leute bis zum Ende des Jahres
sich ein Elektroauto bestellt hätten, was dann erst nächstes Jahr geliefert worden wäre,
wo aber durch diese ganze Unsicherheit, mit kommt es rechtzeitig, kriege ich eine Prämie, kriege ich nicht,
es viele Leute einfach ab der zweiten Jahreshälfte gar nicht mehr gemacht haben.
Das ist auch so etwas, was ich einfach nicht verstanden habe,
wo ich mir gedacht habe, wie kann man das so bescheuert dämlich regeln?
Ich kaufe mir noch kein Auto mehr Ende des Jahres oder gehe in der zweiten Jahreshälfte, wo ich nicht genau weiß, ob ich 2.000, 3.000 Euro mehr oder weniger bezahlen muss.
Also das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mir gedacht habe, wie bescheuert kann man was machen?
Das.
Wir wissen, wo dein Auto steht.
Bewegungsdaten von 800.000
E-Autos sowie Kontakte, also wir sind standen
ungeschützt da. Super!
Die sind alle immer so planlos.
Ich will das noch nicht mal auf die
Entwickler schieben.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass
IT- und Entwicklungsleute
sogar gewarnt haben davor, dass es
unsicher ist,
dass allerdings durchgedrückt wurde
oder aber anderweitig in Kauf genommen wurde, dass das so ist.
Amazon Cloud Speicher, weitgehend ungeschützt zugänglich.
Was heißt denn weitgehend ungeschützt zugänglich?
Also in irgendeinem S3-Bucket oder wo lag das?
Ja, gemeldet hat das vielleicht keiner, weil er Angst hatte, verklagt zu werden.
Tja.
Ich erwarte, dass VW das abstellt.
Wisst ihr, was ich erwarten würde?
Dass man VW abstellt,
bis das behoben ist.
Damit meine ich nicht die Autos.
Aber es muss so teuer werden,
dass das instant behoben wird,
weil es sich sonst
überhaupt nicht lohnt.
Warum wird sowas überhaupt von denen gesammelt? Aus dem Grund, warum ich mittlerweile davon ausgehe, dass alle Daten gesammelt werden. Wir machen es mittlerweile nicht so, wir sammeln nur noch das, also mit wir meine ich so, insgesamt erkenne ich den Trend.
dass mittlerweile nicht einfach nur das gesammelt wird, was man braucht,
sondern dass einfach mal pauschal alles gesammelt wird,
vielleicht braucht man es irgendwann ja nochmal.
Also genau umgedreht.
Nicht überlegen nach dem Motto,
okay, was brauche ich denn alles, um meine Services ordentlich zu betreiben,
sondern lasst mal alles sammeln und dann gucken wir mal, was wir damit machen können.
Wahrscheinlich ist das der gleiche Grund da.
Was man hat, hat man.
Ja.
Womit die Zweckbindung der DSGVO fehlt?
Ja, gut, muss die halt erstmal einer verklagen.
Und das dann irgendwie beweisen.
Da werden die sich schon irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen, warum das notwendig ist.
Ja, schon für den Arsch, ne?
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Bei den E-Autos ist zwar nicht klar, ob es wieder eine Förderung geben wird,
aber die Autobauer müssen definitiv eine bestimmte Quote einhalten.
und wer sie dabei mit einem Kauf unterstützt, der könnte mit guten Deals belohnt werden.
Aber ihr merkt, da ist viel Konjunktiv drin. Ob das tatsächlich so kommt, das ist noch unklar.
Und vielleicht habt ihr ja vor, im kommenden Jahr mit dem Auto nach Großbritannien zu fahren, dann ist das hier wichtig.
Fünftens, neue Regel für Reisen ins Vereinigte Königreich.
Seit dem 1. Februar 2020 ist Großbritannien kein Mitglied der EU mehr.
Dieser sogenannte Brexit hat sich schon in verschiedenen Bereichen ausgewirkt, jetzt kommt etwas Neues dazu.
Zwar braucht man als Reisender aus der Europäischen Union nach wie vor kein Visum für Großbritannien, dafür aber ab dem 2. April etwas anderes, nämlich eine elektronische Reisegenehmigung, auf Englisch abgekürzt ETA.
Die kann man online beantragen und wenn alles geht, wie jetzt, sowas geht da digital und es funktioniert einfach?
Was ist da los?
Was geklappt hat, ist sie für zwei Jahre gültig, es sei denn, der Reisepass läuft in dieser Zeit ab.
Kostenlos ist das allerdings nicht. Die ETA kostet 10 britische Pfund, also umgerechnet knapp 12 Euro.
Bezahlen kann man aktuell nur mit Kreditkarte.
Eine Einreise nach Großbritannien inklusive Nordirland ohne ETA ist ab dem 2. April 2025 nicht mehr möglich.
Falls ihr also Reisen geplant habt, dann am besten demnächst schon mal darum kümmern.
Und damit sind wir beim letzten Punkt Nummer 6, was sonst noch wichtig ist.
2025 tritt in der Europäischen Union eine neue, Achtung, wieder ein unglaublich langes Wort, Plastikverpackungsordnung in Kraft.
Oh, gibt es wieder irgendwelche komischen Dinger an Deckel, Deckel an Plastikflaschen?
Auch dieser Verordnung darf der Weichmacher Bisphenol A, kurz BPA, nicht mehr vorhanden sein, und zwar in Verpackungen, die Kontakt mit Lebensmitteln haben.
Diese Verordnung ist ein weiterer Schritt,
BPA aus unserer Umgebung zu verbannen, weil es ...
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber soll mir recht sein.
... schädlich für unser Immunsystem sein kann.
Außerdem wichtig, ab dem 28. Juni 2025 gilt in Deutschland das,
und jetzt kommt wieder ein langes Wort,
Barrierefreiheitsstärkungsgesetz.
Das bedeutet, dass ab dann auch private Unternehmen
ihre Dienstleistungen und Produkte für Menschen mit Behinderung
uneingeschränkt zugänglich machen müssen.
Eine Ausnahme gibt es nur für ganz kleine Unternehmen.
Heißt, zum Beispiel, wenn ich einen Online-Shop anbiete, also meine Firma oder Unternehmen bieten einen Online-Shop an, dieser Online-Shop ist allerdings beispielsweise so JavaScript-verseucht, dass er für Menschen mit Sehbehinderung nicht richtig nutzbar ist.
Verstoßen die dann dagegen?
... von Menschen mit Behinderung stärken und Teilhabe ermöglichen am alltäglichen Leben.
Das geht auf eine entsprechende EU-Richtlinie zurück.
Und Neuerungen gibt es auch im Sport.
In der Formel 1 fällt 2025...
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass wahrscheinlich eh wieder leider drauf geschissen wird.
Guckt euch mal unsere Bahnhöfe an, wie kack es da ist.
Wie viele Gleise es ohne Fahrstühle und alles gibt.
2020 zum Beispiel der Extrapunkt für die schnellste Rennrunde wieder weg.
Er hatte sich nach Angaben der Verantwortlichen einfach nicht bewährt.
Und im Fußball werden für die 1. und 2. Bundesliga im kommenden Jahr die Rechte neu vergeben.
Das könnte dazu führen, dass es sich wieder ändert, welche Anbieter welche Spiele am Start haben.
Außerdem möchte die Deutsche Fußballliga, kurz DFL, das Programm um die Spiele herum noch attraktiver gestalten.
Künftig soll es unter anderem Interviews bei der Busseinfahrt vor den Spielen geben.
Und die Vereine dürfen ab der kommenden Saison wohl schon während der Spiele Highlights aus diesen Spielen auf ihren Plattformen zeigen dürfen.
Außerdem kommt 2025 für Unternehmen die verpflichtende E-Rechnung mit einer gewissen Übergangsfrist.
Kleinunternehmer können künftig mehr verdienen, bevor sie Umsatzsteuer erheben müssen.
Und auch diese Info der Vollständigkeit halber noch, wer privat Bier braut, darf künftig bis zu 500 Liter pro Jahr steuerfrei herstellen.
Da freuen sich die Bayern bestimmt.
Erst danach hält das Finanzamt die Hand auf.
Ihr seht, ganz viel dreht sich auch im kommenden Jahr ums Geld.
Während es auf der einen Seite Entlastungen gibt,
steigen auf der anderen Seite in vielen Bereichen die Kosten, die Belastungen.
Ob am Ende ein Plus oder ein...
Also ich habe jetzt wenig Entlastungen für mich da festgestellt, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Es ist eigentlich nur teurer.
Also was, was, mir fällt jetzt nichts ein, was mich davon entlastet.
Das hängt von vielen verschiedenen Faktoren ab, aber tendenziell würde ich zumindest sagen, wird es 2025 für uns teurer.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall auch im kommenden Jahr hier auf dem Kanal am Start sein und über diese Dinge sprechen.
Und natürlich würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen, wenn ihr weiter...
Oder am Start, wie der Fabian immer gesagt hat.
Hups, das habe ich zugemacht. Na gut, egal, wir waren eh durch.
lohnt sich tagesgeld bei trade republic und co noch was machen eigentlich meine
stoffe
lasst mich mal kurz gucken musst du denn entlastet wenn klar muss ich entlastet
werden sollten alle entlastet werden ich auch meine meine stoffe scalable doch
Ich glaube schon, dass ich entlastet werden muss.
Ähm.
Markets are closed.
Ja, ach.
So.
Oh ja.
Also.
Dieses Jahr.
Ey, das ist ja mal echt nicht übel.
das ist ja mal echt nicht übel also mein gesamt wie nennt man das depot portfolio also immer ist
um 20.301 euro und 83 cent im wert gestiegen das heißt nicht dass ich die bekomme oder so
prozent sieht man da prozent wenn man drauf klickt nicht
das ist ja die bekomme wenn ich jetzt verkaufen würde würde ich das bekommen
aber sehr nice war doch gut dass ich damals als das angefangen hat so ukraine technisch
wo es komplett im keller im keller war alles gedacht haben so ich kaufe jetzt einfach noch
mal ein bisschen etf nach es hat sich tatsächlich gelohnt
stonks
muss man demnächst ja nicht vor vorstellungen etf hör mal auf also ich
habe für 2023 muss ich nichts versteuern da habe ich sogar von scalable extra ein
pdf dokument gekriegt in den print stand dass keine nennenswerten
transaktionen ich habe es keine nennenswerten transaktionen gab
er hat mich funktioniert ich habe drauf geklickt ich habe auf plus plus 20
stunden kam nichts mit prozent im zweifelsfall muss ich ja nicht ich bin
ja schon dran gewöhnt dass für jeden furz den ich lasse das irgendwie extra
Geld bezahlen muss.
Endlich mal
gescheit Videoempfehlungen hier.
Was hatten die da um den Hals?
Sicherlich irgendeine
Schleife und ein Glöckchen.
Das können Katzen ja in der Regel überhaupt nicht ab.
stell euch mal vor wie nervig klöckchen sind der stelle ich stelle immer vor
bei jedem schritt bimmels keine ahnung
da haben wir sehen was smartphones 2025 werden krass so ich würde vermuten
2025 ändert sich was smartphones angeht verhältnismäßig wenig außer dass es
vielleicht ein paar kameras mehr gibt ein bisschen schnellere cpu sommer der
eine oder andere hersteller wieder sagt klapp handy sind es kommt ja immer mal
wieder alle paar jahre kommt irgendein hersteller auf die idee und sagt aber
wir bauen wieder klapp handy
Irgendwas Spannendes noch hier.
Der neue Ubuntu-Killer.
Ubuntu muss nicht gekillt werden.
Gefälschter Honig in deutschen Super...
Moment.
Aus was besteht der denn, wenn das kein Honig ist?
Achso, wahrscheinlich Wasserzusatz oder so.
neues lohnt sich stimmt da wollte ich tatsächlich mal nachgucken ob es da
irgendwas spannendes gab was verdient ein projekt manager leute ich glaube
das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken da kann ich wieder schön flamen projekt
manager ja projekt manager
Projektmanager
Da muss, okay
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich
rumflamen werde
Oder mal gucken
Obwohl ich in der Bank arbeite, bin ich eigentlich kein Banker
Ich arbeite
By the way
Beziehungsweise, ich habe, by the way, auch in einer Bank
gearbeitet und ich war auch kein Banker
Alle waren da, weil keiner so genau
wusste, wo jetzt die Gefahr war.
Einfach nur drauf hoffen, dass die Tür
so eine Kugel abhält.
Im Jahr verwalte ich ein Budget von ungefähr
einer Million Euro.
Können wir alle meine Träume erfüllen?
Was? Das ist ja nix!
Im Jahr
verwalte ich ein Budget von ungefähr
einer Million Euro.
Eine Million im Jahr?
Ja, das ist ja...
Das ist ja...
Das fällt mir gar nichts ein.
Was ist denn...
Wir brauchen ja den Vergleich besonders klein, das ist nix.
Dafür kannst du ja nicht mal neue Stühle kaufen für die Leute.
Moin, ich bin David, 36 und ich nehme euch heute mal mit in eine Entwicklungsbank.
Ah, okay, das ist nicht an Bank, so wie ich an Bank denke.
Das ist irgendwas...
Entwicklungsbank?
Okay.
Mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit.
In diesem Fall mit einem selbst zusammengebauten Fahrrad.
Das ist einfach die günstigste und schnellste Variante, durch Köln zu kommen.
Oh ne! Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Die DEG ist eine Entwicklungsbank.
Wir arbeiten ausschließlich mit privaten Unternehmen zusammen in Schwellen- und Entwicklungsländern.
Das heißt, ich habe Projekte in Lateinamerika, in Afrika und auch in Asien.
Eigentlich haben wir flexible Arbeitszeiten. Ich kann also kommen und gehen, wann ich will. Hauptsache die Arbeit wird geschafft.
Aber heute sind wir schon ein bisschen spät dran. Ich habe gleich noch ein Meeting mit meinen Kollegen und die warten wahrscheinlich schon auf mich.
Ja, viel zu tun. Moin zusammen.
Ah, schön Open Workspaces. Da haben alle bestimmte richtig Bock drauf. Vor allem, wisst ihr, wer besonders Bock darauf hat?
Besonders Bock haben diese zwei Damen hier da drauf, weil wenn die telefoniert, geht sie ihr auf den Keks und wenn die telefoniert, geht sie ihr auf den Keks, weil da keinerlei Schallschutz, irgendwas dazwischen ist.
Hier haben sie zumindest so Alibi-mäßig noch was dazwischen stehen.
Aber die facken sich schön den ganzen Tag ab mit Telefonieren.
Wir haben auch in diversen Ländern noch Außenbüros.
Da sitzen Kollegen von mir, für die sind eigentlich diese Dokumente als Hilfestellung gedacht,
um dem Kunden zu zeigen, okay, das sind die Dinge, die wir anbieten können.
Und da bekommst du auch eine Förderung.
Das heißt, wir als Bank übernehmen 50 Prozent der Kosten von diesen Projekten zur Förderung der Nachhaltigkeit.
Da kann aber jetzt nicht allzu viel gefördert werden mit knapp einer Million, oder?
Diese Gelder kommen zum einen Teil aus den erwirtschafteten Gewinnen der Bank.
Da kannst du vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, drei Brunnen bauen oder so.
Und in manchen Fällen auch aus Steuergeldern.
Moin, das würde ich einfach mit euch gleich einmal durchgehen, wo ihr denkt, okay, da sollten wir eine Priorität draufsetzen.
Produkte, und da stimme ich dir zu, Erik, es sind halt wirklich sehr, sehr viele momentan.
Deswegen müssen wir da schon ein bisschen was eindampfen, denke ich.
Ist das auch Tossmusik?
Jetzt muss ich mich kurz auf einen Termin vorbereiten.
Ich präsentiere dem restlichen Team gleich ein Projekt, das ich durchführen möchte mit einem Kunden in Kolumbien.
Da geht es um grünen Wasserstoff und nachhaltige Düngemittelproduktion.
Die Projektvorstellung ist immer ein kleines Wagnis, weil man hofft, man hat sich gut genug darauf vorbereitet
und man kann auf jede Frage, die aus dem Team kommt, eine gute Antwort geben.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, das ist eindeutig der Key zum Success, oder?
Was meint ihr?
Ich schaffe.
Und das Team sagt dann, nee, das passt eigentlich nicht rein oder das fördern wir nicht oder
fördern wir nicht.
Erstmal die low hanging fruits holen.
Bin ich in der Höhe, dann muss ich natürlich zurück zum Kunden gehen und dem dann die
Nachricht überbringen, dass es halt nicht geht.
Ja, das sind manchmal dann schon schwierige Gespräche, die man führen muss.
Ich habe heute ein Projekt mitgebracht für Kolumbien.
Finanzieren einer Machbarkeitsstudie.
By the way, darf ich an der Stelle nochmal erwähnen, dass der Fahrradweg südlich und nördlich des Mains bei uns auch noch nicht über dieses Stadium rausgekommen ist.
Und jetzt schon die dritte Machbarkeitsstudie angefertigt wurde innerhalb von zehn Jahren.
Wir haben ja auch noch Zementwerke im Portfolio, wo das natürlich irgendwo interessant sein
könnte.
Das heißt, es wären auch noch gewisse Investitionen bei dem Zementwerk.
Da hast du recht.
Ich gette, dass es in Deutschland gar nicht so einfach ist,
einfach einen Fahrradweg zu bauen.
Wisst ihr, was ich nice finden würde?
Wenn wir so ein Zwischending hätten.
Es muss jetzt vielleicht nicht so krass wie in China sein,
wo bei irgendeinem Bauprojekt gleich noch 5 Bauarbeiter einbetoniert werden.
Und es müsste doch vielleicht auch nicht 30 Jahre
für irgendwas Kleines wie bei uns brauchen, oder?
So was dazwischen wäre doch ganz nice.
so vielleicht
keine Leute, die dabei sterben,
aber innerhalb von zwei, drei Jahren
was auf die Reihe kriegen.
Das wäre doch nice, oder? Das hätte doch was.
Ich bin halt ein sehr
neugieriger Mensch. Nicht nur
im Zusammenhang mit Menschen, sondern auch
neugierig, was Technologie betrifft.
Es passiert einfach jeden Tag was Neues.
Toss, im Zweifelsfall
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Es gab noch lange Diskussionen, das war ziemlich anstrengend.
Drei Stunden später? Okay, da ist ja schon mal jetzt eine Stunde, zwei Stunden.
Also im Prinzip sind 70 Prozent des Tages jetzt vorbei.
Ich kann jetzt erstmal mit meinem Projekt weitermachen.
Moment, krasser High Performer, wenn es erst 12.30 Uhr ist.
Das war richtig cool.
Da gab es dann, ich glaube am Montag gab es Injera aus Äthiopien.
Dann hatten wir noch eine Soljanka, weil wir ja auch ganz viele Kollegen haben, die einfach...
Der Klassiker, Spaghetti Bolognese.
Dann hatten wir noch eine Soljanka.
Nee, doch nicht.
Weil wir ja auch ganz viele Kollegen haben, die einfach aus den Ländern kommen und dann natürlich auch berichten können, ob das alles so authentisch schmeckt.
Ich glaube für den Job, den ich jetzt mache, gibt es keine wirkliche Ausbildung.
Wenn man sich unser Team auch anguckt, wir haben eigentlich alles dabei. Vom Geografen über die Biologin bis hin zu Maschinenbauingenieuren.
Was ist denn,
Chad, ich kenne mich da null aus, aber ich frage mich gerade,
was für ein Anreiz
hat denn die Bank,
für die ihr arbeitet, diese Projekte
durchzuführen?
Hoffen die, dass
sich das irgendwann für sie mal
rechnen wird? Oder ist das eine reine,
wie nennt man das,
eine reine
Wohltätigkeitssache.
Zinsen? Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Wirtschaftlicher und politischer Einfluss in den Ländern.
Okay, so klingt nachvollziehbar.
Eigentlich war der Weg immer relativ klar vor mir.
Ich werde mal eine Ausbildung machen, ein paar Jahre arbeiten, dann vielleicht mal Bauingenieurwesen
studieren und in einem kleinen Statikbüro arbeiten.
Aber dann kam halt ein ziemlich einschneidendes Erlebnis in meinem Leben und das war eine
Ja, relativ kurze, aber sehr intensive Reise nach Äthiopien.
Und da habe ich halt gemerkt, wie spannend das ist und wie...
Ich würde sagen, Hut ab. Das sind so Länder, da würde ich mich nicht hintrauen.
Ja, interessant ist es einfach neue Kulturen, neue Länder kennenzulernen.
Da habe ich nämlich schon die ganze Zeit auf einen Zwischenbericht gewartet.
Wenigstens haben sie ein ordentliches Arbeitsplatz-Setup mit mehreren Monitoren.
Finde ich schon mal nice.
so eine Low-Profile-Tastatur
mag ich nicht, aber kann jeder machen,
wie er will. Aber immerhin zwei Bildschirme.
Ohne zwei Bildschirme oder
sag mal mal ein großer Curved, kann man eh nicht
gescheit arbeiten.
Das ist ganz spannend. Ein Teil des Projektes ist halt auch
eine Insekten-
Farm zur Proteingebindung.
Wenn ich es dann wirklich schaffe, dann nächstes Jahr noch mal
nach Kenia zu fliegen,
um mir diverse Projekte anzugucken,
dann würde ich mir das auf jeden Fall
auch angucken, weil es mich super interessiert,
wie eigentlich diese Fliegen gezüchtet werden und die dann zu Proteinen verarbeitet werden und so weiter.
Also das ist dann das, wo man sich tatsächlich darauf freut.
Als ich im Januar dann in Ecuador war, wurde ein Fernsehsender überfallen und es wurden Geiseln genommen und es gab...
Das ist so eines der Gründe, warum ich da nicht hinfahren würde.
Einfach großes Chaos.
Ich kam dann in die Situation, dass wir auch mit dem Kunden zusammen in einem Pick-up Truck saßen
und versucht haben, uns in Sicherheit zu bringen.
Dann versucht man schon, sich daran zu erinnern, ok, wo drauf sollte ich achten
und wie schützt man sich möglichst gut, zum Beispiel vor Querschlägern.
Hier geht es halt auch um Fragestellungen, Bezertifizierung von grünem Wasserstoff.
da gibt es mein arbeitgeber hat beziehungsweise nicht mein alter
arbeitgeber muss ich dazu sagen der hatte eine notfallnummer für sowas
ich meine ich war nie in solche ich habe so was nie gebraucht aber wenn du dort
angefangen hast hast du so eine merkplatte kommen da gab es unter
anderem eine notfallrufnummer für solche fälle
kannst du anrufen, kannst du sagen, ey, ich bin gerade hier im Urlaub in, was weiß ich, wo war er jetzt, Ecuador,
und hier geht gerade alles drunter und drüber, hier rennen Leute mit AK-47 durch die Straße, ich sitze hier fest.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was dann passiert ist, wenn du da angerufen hast, aber du konntest anrufen.
es wird sich gerade angeschaut,
was ein Projektmanager
bei einer Bank verdient.
Aber es ist keine normale Bank, es ist eine Bank
für Entwicklungsländer.
Nein, nein, nein, du kommst nicht bei den Botschaften raus.
Du kommst bei einer
Krisen-Hotline
oder sowas raus
von meinem ehemaligen Arbeitgeber,
die dann weitere Sachen
in die Wege leiten.
Die haben da wirklich eine extra, eine eigene Krisen-Hotline
betrieben für sowas, für solche
Geschichten.
Weltweit
immer noch viele Diskussionen, wann
Wasserstoff denn wirklich grün ist und wie man
das nachweisen kann.
Die Mittel, die wir zur Verfügung
Batman kommt vorbei, genau.
Das sind
tatsächlich Gewinne, die aus den
Finanzierungen, also den
Darlehen oder Beteiligungen, die die Entwicklungsbank macht, die die DEG macht, kommen. Die Mittel,
die wir dann über das Ministerium bekommen, das sind tatsächlich direkt Steuergelder,
wo wir ein jährliches Budget haben. Das sind Projekte von einem Hafen, wo wir eine Ausbildungsmaßnahme
unterstützen, Telefonmastenbetreiber, wo wir eine Klimastrategie unterstützen, bis hin
zu einem erneuerbaren Energienentwickler, der jetzt grünen Wasserstoff herstellen möchte.
Insgesamt sind es dann circa eine Million Euro, wo ich für Sorge tragen muss, dass die richtig eingesetzt werden.
Gleich haben wir noch ein Kundengespräch mit Ecuador, mit der Nachhaltigkeitsexpertin von einem Hafen in Ecuador.
Die brauchen Menschen, die dann die Kräne und Maschinen vor Ort reparieren, um den Hafen zu versorgen.
Hier sieht man die Auszubildenden im Hafen und wie wir darüber diskutieren, wie auch die Ausbildung abläuft.
Alright, then take care.
Das war schön.
Ich verdiene im Monat 6.500 Euro brutto und nach Abzügen der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
und Pflegeversicherungsbeiträge bleiben dann auf meinem Konto...
Also die Kabine finde ich auch nice, ja?
... 3.828 Euro, ein 13. Gehalt nochmal in Höhe von 6.500 Euro.
Dazu kommt dann noch ein 14. Gehalt, das aber...
Bonus, hä?
wie gut wir im Jahr unser Geschäft machen.
Ja gut, das ist relativ normal.
Und das sind dann 5.440 Euro fest
plus einen variablen Teil von 1.700 Euro.
Was auf jeden Fall sehr ordentlich ist.
Geht doch gut, klar.
Heute war wirklich ein spannender Tag.
Es ist auch Zeit, jetzt nach Hause zu gehen
und Feierabend zu machen.
Also was er jetzt groß macht,
haben wir leider nicht erfahren.
außer vier Stunden gemietet vormittags und nachmittags einen Call nach Ecuador.
Jetzt zeige ich euch mal was ich sonst noch so in meiner Freizeit mache, wo ich dann manchmal
auch noch ein bisschen Maschinenbauingenieur sein kann, nämlich beim 3D drucken.
Ah, exzellent.
Momentan bastel ich Quad an.
Nachdem das ein 3D Drucker ist, der vorne zu ist,
Nee, das ist ein ganz normaler, das ist kein Dings, ähm, wie heißen die Dinger?
Das ist ein Kunstharzdrucker.
Das ist ein ganz normaler, so schichtenweise Drucker.
Riesendrucker, genau.
Der ist aber recht leise, hä?
Dann bastel ich gerade an einer kleinen Halterung für mein Motorrad.
Also als ich das Motorrad gekauft habe für 2000 Euro, aber in Kisten und in Einzelteilen und man wusste halt auch nicht, was alles fehlt.
Naja, und dann habe ich das nach und nach zu Hause dann alles zusammengesetzt. Momentan steht es aber bei meinen Eltern.
Ne, deswegen. Ich dachte halt vielleicht, weil der geschlossen ist, dass das ein Kunstharzdrucker ist, aber ist nicht.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch noch meine aktuelle Baustelle. Das ist die kleine Honda Monkey von auch ungefähr 71.
Die meisten Leute lachen dann und freuen sich über dieses kleine Minimotorrad.
Oh nein, Toss-Musik!
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
Dass man nie gelangweilt ist und dass man immer wieder was Neues lernen kann, das ist
das, was sich an dem Job besonders lohnt.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss,
Ich muss die Musik ausmachen.
Okay.
Was er so wirklich macht, wissen wir auch nicht, oder?
Ich habe jetzt absolut keinen Plan danach.
Die haben gemietet, vier Stunden,
waren Mittagessen
und er hat mit Ecuador telefoniert.
Keine Ahnung.
Schwätzen.
Na gut, er ist Projektmanager.
Was soll er denn sonst machen,
außer schwätzen?
Da ist ein Projektmanager da.
Das ist eines der Hauptaufgaben von Projektmanagern, schwätzen.
Irgendeiner muss das auch mit dem Schwätzen übernehmen.
Leute, ich gehe mir jetzt was zu essen holen.
Und vorher gehe ich mal aufs Klo.
Vielleicht hören wir uns dieses Jahr ja nochmal.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.